I think that would pan out.
I had a similar idea.
Anthony Kumina were alive,
sir.
I love it.
Joe Rogan.
If it was not for you,
oh my God,
this,
this would not exist.
Which is insane.
That is 100 percent actual fact.
I was watching you doing live from the
compound.
Me and Brian Red Band.
We're sitting in my fucking living room
and we were watching you while you were
fucking playing karaoke.
You're singing karaoke with a machine
gun in front of a green screen.
I was like,
this guy,
this guy just set up his own studio like
he already has opie and Anthony show at
the time.
You guys were at Sirius Xm and he just
decided to do this thing in your
basement just for a goof.
Yeah,
it was like a hobby,
but it's like guys who don't have kids,
married,
not married,
don't have kids,
so I don't have anybody telling them
what to do and they also have disposable
income.
Then you get to see what guys really
want to do.
They want to sing karaoke with a machine
gun in front of a green screen.
Yeah.
It was crazy,
crazy gun Guy Karaoke,
so I could do that.
If if I was married,
I would have a wife that would lose her
mind at my living room,
my living room table that you're
supposed to have a candle on and little
chotchkies and stuff is a wide screen,
a computer monitor and a gaming system
right next to the table.
I have a gaming computer that's just
unbelievable.
And I sit there and just play video
games.
So the table itself is a gaming monitor?
Yeah.
The whole tape.
Well it is one of those touch screen
ones.
No,
it's a,
it's a giant wide monitor.
It's like a,
like 40 inches wide.
So that's the table.
No,
it's on the table.
The table's big heavy metal thing,
but.
But it's just everything.
There's vr goggles up on the console by
the TV.
It's just sensors around the room for
the VR.
It's a playground and you're absolutely
right.
Guys will spend their money on having
fun if,
if allowed to.
That's what this place,
this place is insane in my house.
You go to my house,
it's my wife's house.
Say That's how it works.
Have one elk head on the wall.
That's all I have.
That's all you're allowed.
I laugh at guys when they have the,
uh,
the man cave,
like,
dude,
come on down to the man cave.
The chicks aren't allowed down here.
I got this,
the TV that.
And I'm like,
no,
you should replace is the whole house.
She relegated you to one room echo and
you're happy about it.
You're happy that you got one room.
Happy wife.
Happy life.
That's apparently it didn't work.
It didn't work for me.
You know the thoreau quote that I say
way too many times in this podcast,
but I love the quote.
Most men live lives of silent
desperation.
Wow.
Yeah,
that is true.
It's a hundred percent true.
It was,
uh,
I was married for time and it was a,
it was a nightmare.
It was a living hell for me.
The only thing that got me through as
many years as I was married,
because I was married nine years and I
don't remember one happy year out of
those nine,
but I had gotten into radio pretty early
on in that marriage.
Um,
and that was my life.
So I dedicated myself no matter how
miserable anything else in my life was.
I was doing radio.
So I,
I thought it was awesome.
I have a theory about that.
I really do.
I think that a person needs a certain
amount of suffering in their life.
And if you look at some of the all time,
great comics or even all time great
radio personalities like Howard Stern,
Howard Stern,
during his hay day when he was,
the fucking man was miserable.
Right?
Right.
He would talk about it.
He would hide in his basement.
I love those stories.
Here's this guy.
He's the,
you know,
the biggest radio personality ever.
He's,
he's huge.
And yet he's got to hide and he's just
talking about masturbating and hiding
from his wife and he can't get any sex.
And you're like,
it didn't matter if he was huge,
didn't matter if he was famous,
didn't matter how rich he was,
didn't matter.
He's just hide in the basement.
And that anger came out on the radio
like you related to him.
You understood it.
Yeah.
I,
I get that.
Um,
and it worked for me because there was a
lot of misery.
Like when I started doing really well,
we moved back to New York from Boston
after we got fired.
Oh,
opiod myself.
You guys got fired for saying that the
mayor died?
Yeah,
it was an April fool's gag and a.
because we always thought that the
radio,
April fool's jokes was so stupid and
Hokey and uh,
yeah,
we changed the format to all elvis and
it's like after 10 minutes they say
April fools.
So we're like,
let's just go balls out and say the
mayor's dead and have a news guy come on
and report it and everything.
And then it was supposed to subsequently
get more outrageous as the,
uh,
the,
the show went on.
So by the end of it,
there was a Taiwan male hooker in the
car with them and they crashed because
he was getting a blow job or so,
like it was going to get really
ridiculous,
but they stopped it early on and never
allowed us to even mention it.
So people really thought he died.
Although it's kind of stupid.
You go to the one show for your news,
but back then the internet wasn't what
it is now.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It was the inner,
the inner wasn't even,
it was barely a thing.
It was barely a thing.
Uh,
because that was 90,
97 around there.
Ninety eight.
What year did you get on?
You'll probably earlier I was on really
early,
like the eighties.
I was on bulletin board service.
Uh,
and uh,
we used to play Trivia Games with a 300
Baud Modem with people and I thought it
was amazing even then.
And then in,
in the,
uh,
when we were up in Boston,
I bought a digital camera that was just
this giant thing.
And I had a laptop and other giant thing
and I would take pictures of what was
going on in the studio and then post
them that night on a website that I
figured out I used to code the html
myself and make a website,
just post pictures and links and people
thought it was amazing.
Like you're seeing what we talked about
that day.
Uh,
it wasn't instant,
but it was pretty cool.
And then I started doing videos.
I was able to put video like maybe eight
second clips of nude girls if they were
in the studio and pop that up and people
loved it.
Uh,
and then I got a bill from the company
for bandwidth and I didn't know
bandwidth.
It was a $12,000
bill for a month.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because I,
there was no,
there was no compression or anything.
I'm pumping video out to thousands of
people uncompressed.
And uh,
apparently they had that happen a couple
of times.
So they told me just don't do it again.
They didn't make me pay,
which was pretty cool.
But at that point I had to learn about,
you know,
coding and a compression and things like
that.
So you just kept doing it and just put
them in some sort of a compressed
format.
Did you,
uh,
would you use,
do you remember back then?
Oh God,
I think it was like a for audio.
It was real audio,
which was hilarious.
Right.
The little player,
real,
real audio player would pop up.
And then for video got,
I can't even remember what it was,
but it was terrible.
It was all pixilated,
you know,
like 10 frames per minute,
kind of weird things like real audio,
which was everywhere.
They just quit,
gave up around still unless they changed
into something else,
you know,
or kind kinda got bought out by
somebody.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's happens to everything.
But honestly,
if it was not for you and your show live
from the competent and for,
for opiod.
Hilarious.
Because opie and Anthony was the first
radio show that I re what are wherever
realize you don't really have to have a
format.
Yeah.
You can just talk.
It was just kind of a,
a talk thing.
There was a hang,
it was a hang and a lot of the uh,
we,
we were on the same.
It was the same company as Howard Stern,
CBS radio.
Oh,
look at that real still here.
It says it makes stories from your
videos and photos now.
But this is exactly what it is.
It's real.
It's a real player.
Automatically makes videos.
Stories from your best photos.
Sorry,
cut you off there.
I know.
It's like a kind of montage automatic to
for the.
Yeah.
Used to be a good way to watch porn with
Weird Codex Codex when porn had a weird
codex,
you know,
like woo.
Fucking who compiled this?
You'd get it.
You'd watch it on real player.
Get porn from bit torrent.
Yeah.
And then sometimes you wouldn't have
anything on your computer to play.
It was say a Codec not available.
Yeah,
exactly.
Pissed off because he liked to find
they'll fuck.
Yeah.
No,
that thumbnail was awesome.
I got to see.
I remember the first time I ever got a
porn video sent to me.
I was like,
this is crazy.
Yeah.
Watch a porn video.
Before it was just photos,
the photos were insane because,
uh,
I guess it was around the mid nineties.
My brother had picked up a,
uh,
an apple computer.
I don't even know what model it was or
anything,
but it was,
uh,
it was pretty good for the time.
And uh,
I just sat in front of that thing for
hours and hours on end.
Just one porn pick.
It was no videos,
just pictures and you know,
how they used to scroll sometimes it was
a corrupt file,
so halfway down it would just turn white
and pixelated and zigzaggy.
But uh,
just for hours,
just one more,
one more,
one more and just go tick,
tick,
tick.
It would slowly emerged.
It was very,
a very compelling.
Yeah.
You'd sit there and just waiting for the
three d printer is faster now than it
was downloading photos on a 14 k modem.
Yeah.
It's insane to think of the technology
end of it because you got thumb drives
with more memory than entire computers
had just a few years ago.
Uh,
and,
and I remember,
I guess it was Bill Gates or something,
said you'll,
you'll never need anything more powerful
than a for 86 years ago.
And it's like,
what,
a couple of megs of memory and uh,
just crazy the,
the demand for,
for a computer power got way out of hand
and especially with games and stuff
because I'm a huge gaming got now you
download a game,
like a red dead redemption,
two or call of duty and it's 75 to 100
gigs.
Really.
Those games.
Yeah.
And it's like,
that would,
that would have been 100 computers.
And to think of those floppy discs you
used to get games on,
it would have been a pallet stacked up
like six feet high of those discs to
load it on a computer.
So I'm like the old doom games.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
With the.
Yeah.
You just make those sounds and hopefully
it would work.
And uh,
yeah.
Now you just download them.
I haven't been to a gaming store in
years because with the origin or steam,
you just download the game right off of
your,
uh,
offline redemption to you just download
it.
You just download it.
Like,
I don't know who goes to gamestop or
anything anymore.
I mean there's one in the mall I've
seen.
Yeah,
I've seen it.
I don't know.
Maybe if we used games.
Yeah.
Xbox and playstation.
Xbox you could download to,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And playstation.
Yeah.
You just plugged the cat six or whatever
it was.
And was having a conversation with
Jordan Peterson about this yesterday off
air.
I was saying I'm really,
I get concerned because I feel like all
of our information,
like the vast majority of it is now
digital and we have some things that are
written down on paper,
but even paper so it's so easy to break
and burn and fuck up.
I mean,
we lost most of human beings loss most
of the information about Egypt when they
burned the library of Alexandria,
who knows?
I mean,
there could have been all sorts of
schematics and some diagrams,
detailed diagrams,
how they built some of the things they
built,
lost it all,
you know,
that easily could happen to us.
And then we'll be starting from scratch
again.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
when,
when it takes some form of electricity
to,
to get to all this information,
you're really dependent on that.
There's going to be power,
that type of power of forever.
And even if we figured out how to reboot
electricity and say some day in the
future,
what if we have a massive coronal mass
ejection and it fucking nukes the
entire,
the whole grid and all the satellites go
down and we have to start from scratch.
So it's a decade,
two decades before people start
rebuilding computers again.
That actually work well.
They're going to have to decipher all
this information.
They're going to have to figure out
those codex.
They're going to have to figure out,
yeah,
they're going to get drivers to make all
this stuff work.
And you're gonna miss a lot of it.
Yeah.
All the info is literally ones and Zeros
and it has to be decoded and put back
together again
and some important stuff.
If it's on a drive somewhere,
it could just get nuked.
Yeah,
it's gone.
It's gone forever.
All the things that people figured out
gone.
Don't you wish that would happen at
some?
I don't know.
I'm so cynical,
man.
I really have lately more so.
I,
I think over the course of the past few
years I've just gotten more cynical and
uh,
I think social media had a big effect on
me.
Well,
you engaged too much.
Yes,
I did.
I'm off social media now.
I have been for,
for maybe months at least,
you know,
as a personal choice.
Well,
the twitter kicked me off quite a few
times,
but they kick you off just dumb shit to.
It wasn't even.
It wasn't even that bad.
Like wow.
The last one,
it was a,
I was defending Jimmy Norton.
Some girl was on just bashing Jimmy and
uh,
and I was like,
look at you.
I go,
I don't even know what you are.
First of all,
you're either a masculine girl or a
feminine guy and your hair looks like it
was dyed with period blood because she
has to,
and both at God they fucking permanently
suspended me.
That was the back.
Was it bloods period.
Blood.
You can't make fun of that.
You can't make fun of somebody says
looks if the sexuality.
I kind of called him a a fam,
uh,
or,
or a butch,
whatever.
It was never whichever case,
whichever case.
And to this day I still don't know
actually,
but uh,
so I get kicked off a lot.
I have a twitter account now,
but I have not told anybody what the
name is because I just use it for
research for the show because a twitter
gets the news before the news.
Like that's where everything breaks now
on twitter.
You know what's interesting to me,
Louis?
Fair.
Still twitter.
It,
it's,
it's amazing.
You have a read.
Some of the Shitty says evil Jews.
Crazy.
Antisemetic believable,
unbelievable.
And for whatever reason they're scared
to kicking him off.
Yeah,
they won't kick him off.
I guess a Laura loomer is a Jewish kind
of independent reporter girl,
and a nutcase slash nutcase,
whatever.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Whatever you want to change or
something.
She changed herself to twitter.
Yes.
Hilarious.
I just watched it on periscope as it was
going on and she's got a bull horn and
she's just yelling,
uh,
at twitter as a bull horn,
you know,
it's funny.
It's kind of left wing tactics she was
using because conservatives,
the right Republicans,
whatever you want to call are pretty
mellow when it comes to they don't
demonstrate really.
They like to just get in there and do
their shit,
whatever it is.
Uh,
but liberals really like getting out
there and marching and yelling and bull
horns and stuff like that.
So it was weird,
like to see that on the other end.
Uh,
but she,
she just screaming and uh,
I guess I guess they unhooked her and
uh,
and arrested ourselves.
Ready?
What did they,
what did they kick her off at twitter
for?
They kicked her off.
We're talking about Islam and talking
about how twitter was celebrating a
women's Day,
whatever,
whatever.
That was a on a certain day by focusing
like the picture was one of those,
uh,
Islamic women that got elected to office
up in,
what was it,
Minnesota or somewhere,
so she said how hypocritical that was
because,
you know,
Islam is for female genital mutilation
and,
uh,
against women's rights and they kill gay
people and,
and that's all she posted and she got
kicked off for hate speech against
Islam.
And then her argument was Louis
Farrakhan was saying,
you know,
I'm not an anti Semite,
I'm an anteater,
might equating Jews with insects,
which is pretty 19 thirties,
jeremy kind of a thing.
So,
uh,
you know,
while her heart was in the right place,
I guess it did come off a little wacky.
She also had a star of David,
a yellow star of David on her shirt,
uh,
as she was chained to twitter and people
got upset with that.
Ah,
there she is.
I just thought,
to tell you the truth,
I thought it was a good strategic move
because you're going to buy time with
that because the police do not want that
optic of a uniformed guy kind of pulling
a girl off.
They're wearing a star of David.
They could just picture looks bad.
So it might've bought her some time,
but I don't know if that was her motive.
She planned it out.
Well,
she did.
Apparently it was the number one
trending topic on twitter,
which is odd that you know,
she gets kicked off and ends up being
the number one trending topic.
What's really odd is this is while
Manafort who may have perjured himself
yours going after trump's deeper ties.
Cohen is now saying that trump was in
cahoots with Putin.
He was going
to give them the $50,000,000
penthouse tower in Moscow.
You know,
all that.
But like,
no,
no.
That girl got kicked off,
pick up to it.
It sounds ridiculous because I got,
like I said,
I got kicked off and I'm,
I'm
a little bummed about it.
Uh,
but uh,
it's why,
because it's odd.
It's not just a private company anymore
that can do what they want.
I'm not free government regulation,
so I don't know how you fix this,
but twitter is now a thing where the
presidents on it,
we're leaders are discussing things on
it,
emergency management,
fema and the weather services.
They put out alerts in case of a danger
or or some kind of event that's going to
happen and because of your political
ideology or calling a girl period,
blood hair,
you're not privy to alerts and safety
information that
well,
it's.
It's clear that it's not.
Everyone's doesn't have to follow the
same rules.
We've already established that with
Farah Khan.
We've also established that with trump.
Sam Harris has been on a.
He was,
at least,
I think he's abandoned it,
but it was on a quest to get jack to try
to hold up his terms of service
agreement and kick trump off of twitter.
I was like,
look what he's doing.
He's threatening nuclear war.
Do you understand that?
This is the craziest use of twitter
ever?
Yeah,
and I think Jack's position was that.
It is.
It's more beneficial to have him on and
it's really,
we're getting to see his personality in
a way we've never seen any president's
personal.
Absolutely mean the,
the most ridiculous petty shit that he
does,
like attacking Michelle Wolf because of
her White House correspondents dinner.
You,
Colin people losers,
you know,
making fun of the girl on Joe
Scarborough,
the girl he married.
Yeah.
That she had fucked up plastic surgery.
Her bleeding just make shit up.
I mean,
do you think she really,
really thinks she showed up?
Uh,
Maro Lago,
bleeding fucking plastic surgeries.
He's a fucking maniac.
It really is.
But meanwhile that,
it,
it's good for us to see because it
educates us to who he is as a real
person.
There's a lot of who you are just gets
exposed in those tweets.
We little bit.
You can't know everything about a person
from their twitter,
but you can get,
you can parse out little chunks where
you get a good taste.
And for him it's very,
very revealing.
Yeah,
it is a weird thing.
This is what I think this will be looked
back on as a very pivotal moment in
American history and in politics where
that kind of crossroad happened.
Yeah,
because we were,
we were pretty satisfied with,
uh,
that political speech thing that,
and we need to bring up the lower middle
class and they just go on and on and
drone on.
It's this weird speech that no real
human being ever speaks.
Like Hillary was hilarious.
And why Wayne?
Hey,
today is the guy.
It was fake.
It comes off as fake and phony.
Trump comes rolling in.
It's absolutely batshit insane.
Like the stuff he says,
like you were saying the other day,
he's,
he's giving a speech and he said that
when he was younger people said he
looked like Elvis because he was doing
some kind of a commemorative thing for
Elvis,
um,
uh,
down in Tennessee or somewhere.
And he says,
uh,
he looked like Elvis and we're laughing
our asses off me and Keith,
uh,
because no one ever told me Elvis,
no one ever told him that.
And,
and,
and there's so many things.
And I'm a trump guy.
I voted for the guy because I wanted
that monkey wrench thrown into the
machine.
I felt we had gotten screwed too many
decades and it was time to let
Washington know,
like,
look,
we'd rather elect this nut than any of
you guys.
So I think it proved a point.
Uh,
there are enough checks and balances in
place where,
you know,
the likes of any one president really
isn't going to do that much damage.
I think he's pulled the cover off a lot
of stuff.
I think people are trying to compete
with him on twitter.
Politicians are trying to play his game
and it's kind of fun to watch as a comic
entertainer.
It's gold.
Do you see what Tulsi Gabbert said to
him?
What?
She's a congresswoman from Hawaii.
She said,
uh,
being Saudi Arabia,
bitch isn't making America first.
That's a congresswoman.
Say they're all kind of taking that.
They never used to do that.
No,
they didn't.
And it's odd that a 70 year old guy was
the one that was like bringing twitter
to social media into this forum.
It is on and yeah,
you would think it would be some young
guy get in there and do it,
but I'd never do it the way he's doing
it.
No,
that's just like a reckless maniac.
It's,
and,
and that's because he can.
Yeah,
the guy you,
you'll never see a chain of events like
what happened to elect Donald Trump,
the rich guy.
He's a billionaire and billion,
whatever you want to call him.
He's got a lot of money from his dad,
from his,
his dad.
And then,
you know,
I remember him in New York when I was a
kid.
Trump was always in the news developer.
He was always banging heads with
politicians,
trying to get some kind of zoning thing
going or build some other tower
somewhere.
And uh,
so we were all familiar with them and we
knew he was like this piece of shit guy.
Like everyone was surprised,
like,
Oh God,
he grabbed her by the pussy.
He's like,
we saw in the daily news and the New
York Post every week,
trump was with some other hula is.
So it wasn't a surprise to us.
Uh,
but he got out there and it was the
perfect timing,
like we come off the,
uh,
the heels of eight years of a Democratic
president,
uh,
and it just was,
people were ready for a maniac to be in.
The white people were,
some people were exactly my favorite
image of the election was that lady with
the sock hat on her knees with the
glasses screaming.
That to me ushered in this era of
outrage and chaos.
Yeah.
It just said that was like the primal
scream that set off the dominoes and
they're all in motion right now.
It wasn't supposed to happen.
Hillary was supposed to be president.
That's what everybody thought it was
going to go down in history as just one
of those wacky elections.
And then business as usual.
But,
uh,
you know,
when,
when trump won,
it turned everything upside down and rip
the cover off of,
I think,
not only politics in Washington,
but uh,
Hollywood,
uh,
the mainstream media,
the news media,
everything had the covers ripped off and
everyone's now got a peek inside and
realize how fucked up everything is.
You used to assume Washington,
at least the people had some kind of
control like they were,
they were adults doing the job that
needed to be.
And then you realize,
oh my God,
everyone's just a piece of shit.
Do you remember?
Here's the story that disappeared from
years ago.
Do you remember the Washington Madam,
that suicide or self?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Book filled with politicians that were,
uh,
getting there.
We're banging all these prostitutes and
she was going to release everything and
she was doing press conferences and then
she committed suicide,
committed suicide.
But it's like,
well,
case closed,
you know,
no big deal that will last her books.
Yeah,
yeah.
Whatever,
whatever,
whatever.
And then it disappeared.
It disappeared.
Things like that happen.
Oh,
flag politicians killed people.
Oh yeah.
There's,
there's secret backroom deals that
happen and it's crazy.
House of cards is way closer to reality
than people would like to believe.
Yeah.
Closer.
We,
uh,
over the course of the decades upon
decades,
uh,
every year that goes by,
we seem to get a little more knowledge
and a little less confident in the
government.
I mean,
I watched some shit from the fifties,
you know,
there's plenty of things on youtube and
even even industrial films,
just this thing of how a family,
how to raise your family.
There had to be a good wife,
all that stuff.
And it was all this weird propaganda of
what America was.
And then as years go by,
you realize,
oh,
it was all bullshit.
Like politicians were always getting
rich and no one seems to know how or
why.
And these deals that are made aren't
always in our best interest.
They're not civil servants there to
represent and help you.
And,
and,
and as the years go by,
we see more and more of this and the
past two years with trump has just been
a man quite a crash course.
It really has.
Yeah.
It's great.
I'm fascinated to see where it goes.
I'm fascinated to see if he seems,
you know,
I mean they always called
Godaddy,
the Teflon Don,
but it seems like trump is the teflon
donald.
I mean,
he seems,
it seems like all these things keep
happening and,
and even because I remember Justin
Martin Dale,
a comedian friend of mine is hilarious.
He goes,
uh,
he was talking about stormy Daniels.
He was like,
she's our Monica Lewinsky.
She's going to take them down the fuck.
That's not happening.
No,
you don't get it.
He doesn't care that they know he fucked
her.
Yeah.
He doesn't care to understand.
It's not.
You have to care for it to work.
Right.
And that's just it.
People don't really care.
It's a,
well,
some people don't care.
I,
I follow like Rosie O'donnell's account
on twitter and Rob Reiner is another one
and for two years,
over two years they have just been like
counting down and the day that it's
like,
oh,
impeachments right around the corner.
Oh,
he's out.
they're gonna.
Put them in prison.
I hope you and your son get a cell next
to each other and it's like,
how long are you going to do this?
Eight years.
Is it going to be eight years of you
going?
Well any day now Keith Miller is going
to.
Yeah.
Do you remember when he was doing that
wacky show in a basement somewhere for
Gq,
like a mental patient,
like legitimately like a mental patient
resistance screaming and it was like he
was doing like.
It was almost like burlesque or
something.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you know how it was like the radio
version of burlesque is like when you
see a girl doing burlesque,
it's like a throwback to an old timey
way of doing things.
Like the guy,
the handlebar mustache with a bowler
capital introducer.
She's body,
she is bodacious.
Please welcome Matt.
I'm blah blah blah.
And she comes out to music that nobody
listens to anymore and she's dancing
around.
It's very end.
They're there.
They're always kind of big girls.
They're not skinny little strippers.
There are girls who eat,
so it's like it's a throwback to a
different time of,
of rowdiness and when he was in front of
that screen,
like doing this thing with his suit on
and tie like d and everything was like
really well written and these precise
points and I don't understand like what
the red blue and the background was
either.
It's just,
it was.
So it seemed like something that someone
had set up,
like not as good as your compound of
the.
Yeah.
You live from the compound.
It wasn't,
it wasn't as good as that.
It's like that's the background.
This is for Gq.
Gq was like,
okay,
we have $30 dollars I think.
Uh,
I think uh,
Charlie's got a camera.
He could bring it in $30.
Good.
Okay.
We have a table,
the Ikea table.
That's $12.
You have $18 left.
We got some construction paper for the
background.
What the fuck is this?
I got some big ass blue and blue and red
paint.
Yeah.
Posters.
Like what,
what is that?
And then he would just pontificate there
and he and his last thing was like,
because the end is eminent,
there's no,
no reason for me to go on.
Right.
If it's finished.
Yeah.
What is this?
My work here is done play some of this.
Trump is finished in one year.
One year ago.
This week.
Exactly.
One year ago.
Last November 11,
2017.
It was when he quit.
Get a pardon from trump,
wore the bowler as I've also reported
here,
has succeeded in finding a way around
trumps.
Pardon?
Power in either of these near
certainties spelled trump's do.
So that's the most obvious of the seven
ways for trump to go.
Now smaller.
Really,
we'll get him on Russia.
It will be ugly.
It will tear this country nearly apart,
but it will be necessary.
The second way is as I've also
repeatedly suggested here,
that Mahler doesn't really need to prove
anything about trump and Russian
sabotage of the election.
There seems to be so much obstruction of
justice for the firing of James Comey to
the lies about trump jr's meetings with
the Russians,
that it's hard to pick out a key player
in the trump inner circle who could not
be guilty of it.
It's so funny.
A year ago and it's like,
it's still going.
Still going.
Still going and it gets fake news.
Yeah.
And it now fake news.
It's a hoax,
but it is interesting.
Like molar to me,
it's fascinating because he seems like a
ruthless motherfucker takes his time.
He's like a guy says,
hey,
look at me.
I'm going to kill you.
It's not going to be today.
Okay.
That's all you need to know.
Yes I can be today,
but I'm going to fucking kill you.
And like every day he's plotting on
killing you.
You see them drive by your house in ways
like when is,
when is the hammer fall?
And you look out your window of your
office.
He's out here.
Look at that guy drinking coffee.
Oh,
he has seen some shit.
this guy,
he's.
Yeah.
I mean he's a cold blooded intelligence
agent.
Yeah.
Yeah,
those guys have seen everything.
He knows the inner workings,
the machine,
and he knows how you bring a guy like
that down and how you fuck it up and
he's doing everything.
That leads me to believe that he's not
fucking it up.
This is a slow play and if there is,
if there is anything to the Russian
thing,
you would think something would have
leaked out by now.
Well,
it has.
I mean it was,
there was a video the other day of
Donald that they just played on cnn of
Donald was talking about how many times
he's actually been to rush donald junior
and you know,
he had said that he hadn't been.
But then there's another video of him
from years ago saying,
yeah,
I've been there many times.
Five,
six,
seven,
eight,
talking about business.
The problem with,
uh,
the people that are going after trump,
they don't seem to understand the guy
right up until he became president of
the United States was just a private
citizen businessman.
So he had a lot of dealings around
the world with his real estate and
buildings and golf courses.
All this shit happened when he was just
a citizen doing business now,
whether it was ethical or not,
um,
that,
that could definitely be brought into
question,
whether it's legal or not a,
I'm sure that's what they're looking
into also,
but he wasn't,
he wasn't beholden to the people as a
public servant.
There wasn't a conflict of interest
because he was a lifelong politician and
using the power of his office to make
deals so,
and that also goes hand in hand with him
just fucking around.
Like,
like if he went from a selectman in his
hometown and then years and years go by
and then you're the president and you
built that career up.
Any at any point in there they could
call you out on being a horrible human
being because you fucked girls or you're
this.
So you'd had a shady business dealings.
But up until two years ago,
he was just donald fucking trump.
Yeah.
So it's hard to call them out on even
dealing with Russia because there's
plenty of business and deal with Russia
and China.
I think the question is whether or not
he colluded with Russia to get
information about Hillary and also to to
to put out all that propaganda against
Hillary and also saying that they're
going to make a deal to do the trump
tower in Moscow.
This is all while he was running for
president.
Not being honest about it.
I think that's,
that's where it gets again.
I don't know almost there's anything
illegal there.
I don't know if there's anything that,
that he did that is illegal because I
believe when you're campaigning say
whatever the fuck you want to anybody
really running.
I mean you're really running anything.
It really running the country.
Yeah.
If he lost the presidency,
he would still have to have some ducks
in a row to continue his business.
So you know,
and his son took over that part of,
of what he was doing so he could
campaign.
So whether Donny Jr went over to Russia
or not,
I don't really see.
You might think it's unethical and you
might go,
well,
did he say if we win,
we'll do this and help you out.
So who knows about that part of it,
but I don't see in and of itself him
going over there being that big a
problem and the fact that,
you know,
the Clinton campaign and the DNC,
they had a lot of shady deals going on
with Russia also in that crazy dossier
and an English spy and a Russian like.
And that just never seems to get any
traction.
It's weird.
Well,
there's way more left wing media
publications in the right way.
Absolutely.
Just the fact there's only a few right
wing,
uh,
newspapers and right wing websites are
oftentimes maligned,
treated seriously.
Like there's no right wing newspaper
that's treated with the same amount of
respect is the New York Times columnist.
It doesn't exist.
Now.
What the,
uh,
the New York Post,
the New York Post right wing.
Outrageous.
Yeah.
They don't give
a fuck who you are.
Liberal Democrat,
Sro,
conservative Republican.
They'll fuck you.
Some of the headlines that have come off
of the fucking post have been classic
over the years.
They're amazing.
Yeah.
Like comics.
It's just comedy.
One was one I thought was just so
douchey when Fred astaire died,
it was said a stairway to heaven like
fucking,
but that someone must have gotten a hit
for this.
The one thing that I do love about New
York and Boston to yeah,
is a harshness to the comedy because
people are fucking cold.
It's cold in the wintertime is calling
like fuck you and that growing up there,
man,
it fucking flavored me flavored bourbon.
There's a million guys like that that
like that.
Patrice,
that fucking comedy.
A lot of it came out of that part of the
world because that part of the world is
different.
Isn't that weird?
It's,
it's cold and you think that just makes
people angry.
A cold and a lot of people I think and
very few people makes people like more
down home.
Me and compassionate and they stay
together.
Tana,
except for a few serial killers randomly
scattered,
scattered out into the woods,
but other than that you get like people
that work together and help each other
because they realized they were in this
together.
Yeah,
there is A.
There's a stark difference between New
York and Boston based comics and La
based company.
It's amazing difference.
Yeah.
And some of them have that crossover
appeal there and they've moved,
you know,
and uh,
like bill,
but maintains that Boston sensibility,
that New York sensibility.
Yeah.
What's appealing about him is that he's
still a savage,
right,
exactly.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Like that.
You don't grow that out here.
It's sunny,
it's nice every day.
Everyone's a.
everyone's seems kind of pleasant out
here,
whether it's real or phoniness,
but it comes off as pleasantry and in
New York is just a grave disregard for
everybody.
Uh,
you literally step over people.
Many people lose their value.
Yeah.
Like if you have a million pennies and
you drop a penny,
put up.
Shit.
Lost the guy on the train.
Now it is odd when you think about if
there was somebody just laying in the
gutter of the street in some small town
in Kansas,
uh,
the police and ambulance would be called
and people would stop and ask if he was
okay.
And,
and in New York you literally step over
those people.
You just don't even look in their face.
It's a.
it's an inconvenience that someone is
laying on the sidewalk.
If you were in the middle of a snowstorm
and you were,
your car broke down and you saw a guy
laying on the side of the road.
Yeah,
you'd help him.
Of course.
He'd be like,
oh,
Jesus,
poor guy.
Look,
we've got to help him to.
Hey Buddy.
You're alright.
Yeah.
Not so
much New York,
New York.
You just see him lying in his own piss
needle hanging out of his dick.
And I'm pissed that it stinks down in
the subway.
Fucking gross.
Like fucking disgusting,
man.
Yeah.
No compassion stink too though.
In a steamy August day.
It's the worst and it's gotten worse.
Uh,
under uh,
Deblazio who's a mayor of New York now
and say what you want about Giuliani,
who now is batshit crazy?
What happened with him?
I don't know.
I blew a fuse.
He's not respectable anymore.
He's like some kind of.
Well,
he aligned himself with trump,
so that immediately gets you put into a
category.
But he's also a little.
I think he's got some dementia going on,
like he just doesn't seem right.
It is lost his comb over that he had a
comb over for,
what is that?
Like a,
what's his name with the comb over and
he realized,
Oh my God,
I'm fucking crazy.
Samson's hair.
It's like that.
He,
he lost the last wisps,
those last wisps of comb-over yeah.
That he'd had during nine slash 11 going
on.
Yeah,
he was at one point,
you know,
after nine slash 11,
they call it nine,
10,
2011.
He was a piece of shit.
No one liked Giuliani.
He ruined New York.
He ruined it by commercializing it,
cleaning up all the porn theaters.
Uh,
getting rid of the tunnel bunnies and
the squeegee guys like he went on a
tear,
just gave the police department carte
blanche to start racking head and taking
care of business.
A cleaned up New York Times Square
turned into a Disney type atmosphere
instead of that drug addled fucking mess
that it was.
And,
and people hated them for kind of
ruining that Gritty New York that we saw
in taxi driver and shit.
And then nine slash 11,
he was America's mayor.
That's what they called them,
America's mayor.
He's going to Yankee Games and ovations
and people.
He's standing with the other.
He looked so crazy.
Person on the right.
Yeah.
He is totally shaved his head to talk to
them.
I say,
listen Bro,
there's a lot of power in just shaving
your that head motherfucker.
Yeah.
You feel good.
You feel like a guy who has like hair on
the side of his head,
unless you do a lot of drugs like
hunter,
s Thompson.
It's hard.
You can't pull that off,
I think.
Yeah.
Uh,
for right hand side.
That's a,
that's a comb over in the beginning.
Yeah.
Above that.
Above that to right to the right of the
suit.
Look at that.
Oh yeah.
That's where it's first started.
That's the full.
Oh my God,
look at that.
Oh,
the back.
Like what did he do?
Did he try to get plugs or something in
the front?
I don't think so.
I don't know what that is.
It's just rocking the full strong
comb-over that is.
Uh,
he,
uh,
he had a lot to do with the,
the,
um,
getting rid of organized crime in New
York City,
like the mafia,
the five families,
all that shit was still running pretty
rampant throughout the seventies and
eighties as
a kid.
Me and my brother used to laugh our
asses off.
We'd open the newspaper and it was like
Johnny the Horse,
he was found dead.
And so we laugh our asses off at the
names,
like just those,
those mob names.
It's hilarious.
And that scene in Goodfellas at the
beginning when they're just going
through and,
you know,
the nose and killer and this guy and
they all have those fucking names that
are hilarious.
And uh,
yeah,
Juliana was a big part of that.
I'm surprised they didn't kill him.
Like he was absolutely irresponsible.
He kept going after them and kept
putting them away with the,
you know,
the new Rico statutes that they had and
a locked up.
A lot of mobsters,
man.
So,
well,
you know,
another problem with the mom says they
started rapping.
I mean,
yeah,
yeah.
As soon as you start ratting on each
other all year,
mystique is gone.
Your whole,
your whole legend is gone.
This the whole thing is that you guys
have Omerta.
You keep your fucking mouth shut.
You do your time like a man when you get
out and you're a hero and this whole
thing keeps going.
This thing of ours,
this thing was,
but those fucking pussies didn't want to
go to jail.
Isn't that something like the old school
guys would be offered,
you know,
you can walk or you could get a really
easy sentence.
Just talk a fuck your mother and,
and,
and then yeah,
if they reached the point where it's
like,
yeah,
I,
I'm not built for prison.
When they would put them in prison
though,
it was like in Goodfellas it would be
able to cook and they paid the guards
off a sweet setup.
The internet ruined all that too.
Yeah.
You went,
well it was probably all dead before the
Internet,
but,
but you know,
like Sammy the bull Gravano,
he was free.
He did his time to the minimum amount of
time he killed at least 10 people that,
I mean,
he,
he confessed to them,
you know,
talked about the morality did and how he
did them.
He wanted it so bad.
They wanted it so bad.
Let me,
Sammy the bull gravano was a fucking
straight up psychopath.
Yeah.
That's total serial killer.
And they let him walk and then he got
arrested eventually for selling ecstasy
in Phoenix.
He moved to Phoenix after that.
Yeah.
And then he was running shit down there.
And how did he just not get whacked out?
Like was the mob was gone.
They all were gone.
No one cared.
Hated it all.
It all crumbled at that something.
Yeah,
just like A.
poof.
Went away.
The thing that like,
he was the first one that was like real
flashy and public about that.
They didn't like that.
Vincent the Chin always used to walk
around like a crazy person in the
bathroom.
Bathroom.
It was nuts.
But he would,
he would give people directions while he
was doing that,
but he felt like everything was being
bugged so that they would do,
is they have bugged cars along his
walking route.
They can record him.
Oh,
that is hilarious.
What he was doing.
Jesus.
There's always a way.
There's always a way to get you.
Yeah.
The mystique was gone though.
It wasn't really like the Russians still
have the mystique Russian mobsters.
They are brutal,
scary ones.
Like they are the scary ones.
There's a worse ma because regardless of
what it turned into,
there was a time where the Italian mob
did have a line.
Like you didn't cross family,
things like that.
Uh,
but the Russians,
all my God,
will they fuck up an entire family?
The dog.
Everything gets killed in the worst way.
Yeah.
They're scary.
Scary motherfuckers.
I had a,
an experience.
I'm out.
It was a broadway I guess.
Uh,
and they have those peddle cabs that go
around and they were all Russian dudes,
big legs on them.
And they peddle around and I was looking
for a cab or real cab to take me
downtown.
I wasn't gonna ride 15 blocks in a
tricycle with Uri peddling in front of
me.
So,
uh,
this guy passed by once and said,
you need the cab.
I was like,
no,
I'm good,
thanks.
Comes around again.
I'm still waiting for a cab and he goes,
cab.
And I was like,
I'm not going to have you pedaled me 15
fucking blocks.
No move.
And,
and you could yell at a cab driver in
New York.
They'll yell out your window and stuff.
They've rarely will get out of their
car.
They know,
you know,
you've got the medallion right there.
You could just call the number and say
you were being harassed by a cab driver
so they won't do anything.
This guy gets off his fucking bike,
you have a fucking problem.
Fucking problem was.
And I was just like,
oh shit,
it's going down.
This guy means business.
And of course I'm like,
no,
no.
All good.
I thank you.
I don't need a a cab.
You'll write the motherfuck and that was
it.
But you don't fuck with Russia.
No,
they're not regular white people.
they're not.
They're not.
They're hard people.
Yeah.
You see that in the UFC is a lot of bad
ass rush.
Well,
obviously we should know.
We saw that a recent.
Yeah.
When was on top of connor punched him in
the face saying let's talk.
No talk.
Boom,
let's talk.
Come up.
We'd talk.
Boom.
Just twisted.
Terrific.
Yeah.
And then they got those other videos
that you see on youtube and whatnot of
Russians just up in a steel.
Ibm's yeah,
like a hundred stories up backflips
swinging back backflips hanging bike.
Two fingers in that and sometimes
falling.
Yeah.
My hands are sweating.
You just talking about that makes my
hands feel like it is so uncomfortable
to watch.
And uh,
because they're,
they get themselves in these positions
where maybe there's this thin little
alcove and,
and they put their hands against one
side their feet against the other.
If your feet slip,
there's no.
No.
Recovering drives me crazy is not.
Look,
I got goosebumps.
Is it a weird to get a visceral reaction
to just the thought.
And I have some friends that just know
that I freak out.
So they sent me those.
Every Christ.
Yeah.
There are some things
that,
uh,
are online.
Scott,
what the fuck?
Oh my God.
Oh.
Oh,
they are nuts.
I can't do this man.
My hands are pouring ca.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Look at this crazy ass hole.
Crazy shit.
Oh.
What does it say?
Dare Devil returns with latest shocking
stunt on skyscraper.
This fucking mother fucker.
But he's doing a handstand on.
What is that?
A three inch ledge.
Oh God.
Come on.
Come around the corner.
What are you doing this?
You fuck a one little.
One.
Little fucking miscalculation.
Or how do you do that?
How do you know your center of gravity?
Is it just gonna?
Pull your right.
The fuck up.
Jesus Christ.
He went around the corner.
That's nuts.
What is this guy's lifelike?
If he decides he's going to do this?
This makes me very uncomfortable.
That is so fucking high up.
It's so high.
That is so high.
I wouldn't,
I can't do what he did if he was on the
ground,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I can't.
I can't do those handstands and all that
jazz brown mark out three inches and try
to stay on it with your hand or mark it
up enough so that you like put pads
under me.
Right,
right.
And then give it so I could jump up and
grab it and hang out.
See how much of that I could do,
like a couple of things.
I could king from my fingers.
I might be able to pull myself up,
but if I got to the top I probably slip.
Yeah.
Your height will definitely fuck with
you.
Like if you're riding a bike on a
sidewalk,
you will never fall off the sidewalk.
You could just ride your bike.
You don't even have to think about it.
Sidewalk what?
Couple of feet wide.
If that was over like the Grand Canyon,
you,
you would be shaking.
You couldn't do it.
And it's the same fucking thing.
It's just your perception and the height
and you know,
you'd be,
you'd be fucked up.
You'd be like,
there's going to fall off.
We have that htc vibe in the back room
here.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
And uh,
there's one game we have to download
that game.
We haven't gotten that game when you go
to the hardware store and you buy a two
by four and you lay it down on the floor
and then the game is,
you put the vr goggles on and you're
walking on this two by four over,
like in between two skyscrapers.
Right?
So as you're doing it in here,
so this is,
this is the actual game.
Oh my God.
You step out.
Oh,
here's the two by four.
So this two by four is real.
Like you have an actual two by fours
really walking on this.
So you're feeling it and you walk the
plank.
Oh my God.
And you look down,
you're like,
what is that thing floating in front of?
You don't know.
What's that supposed to be,
Jamie?
I've never done it.
I don't know.
It's uh,
yeah,
the uh,
first of all watching it on a screen
does vr no justice.
You can't really,
you are in a space.
It's so cold to kind of look around.
They,
they definitely have more work to do.
Yeah,
it's a,
it looks cool.
You feel like you're in a three d
environment,
but it's not very photo realistic.
No.
Uh,
for kids are addicted to it.
Really run here afterschool.
Oh really?
Put the vr goggles.
They fight over it and they put the vr
goggles on and play these fucking crazy
games.
Yeah.
Uh,
I have,
uh,
the Oculus and the vive and the
playstation vr at home and right now the
Oculus is the highest quality of the vr
goggles.
Um,
I think playstation has some pretty cool
games out there though.
[inaudible]
does too,
but I think uh,
a Oculus is going to come out very soon
with a completely wireless one.
So it was a htc vive.
Yeah.
So you're not tethered to anything and
you're tripping over wires and shit.
That's going to be big.
Yeah.
That,
that's pretty huge.
It's weird though because uh,
some games aren't conducive to vr and
you would think like I play call of duty
or battlefield five World War II thing
just came out and I love that,
that game.
But I couldn't play that for our
[inaudible].
I will play for fucking hours on end and
to have the goggles on that long and uh,
trying to play a shooter like that.
Um,
I think vr right now is more conducive
to experiences than it is like that.
That's pretty much not a game.
It's an experience and it brings you
into a whole nother three d world around
you.
But uh,
like a shooter game,
like battlefield or call of duty not
really conducive to vr right now.
Not yet.
Yeah.
I think in the future though,
a plastic gun.
Yes.
Like a real.
If you were holding a real plastic,
you'd need that interface.
Yeah.
That would be fucking amazing for a
shooter game.
Yeah.
There's a few other ideas that they're
working on that should be available
pretty relatively soon where the system
maps your house,
like the room you're,
you're in off of your headset and will
superimpose things over the couch.
Like it'll be a ammo crate.
A chair turns into a box ammo crate.
So as you walk around the room,
uh,
it's reading your room,
but making this vr world that looks more
military or like a jungle or whatever it
is,
so it won't be a couch,
you'll hit it,
but in your vision it'll be a box or an
ammo crate or you know,
what a car,
something like that.
So,
uh,
that's kind of cool.
Uh,
utilizing,
uh,
the real environment around you and then
superimposing shit over it.
You know,
what else is really cool?
The boxing games.
Yeah.
And the boxing games,
you get a crazy workout,
you get a real legit workout because
you're actually fake boxing this cartoon
character.
And when you get
hit you see a bright white flash like,
like you got.
Yeah,
like you got hit like you got your Bell
Rung You,
but you get,
you get a real workout when you're doing
this.
So yeah,
breath.
I've watched,
uh,
my,
my girl plays that and it's hilarious.
It's funny to watch people do Vr,
especially stuff like that because
they're ducking.
There's another shooter game that she
was playing and it's hilarious because
she's screaming and ducking down and
your hand is up like pulling a trigger
on a fake gun over something that isn't
even there.
So it's,
it's cool to watch people play.
It was some crazy Zombie game that my
kids play.
It's like you get a bunch of guns and
ammo and then the zombies are closing in
on.
You got a gun.
I'm down.
Yeah.
This is weird.
I'll tell you,
there are some games or experiences
where you're walking through a kind of a
haunted house thing that are genuinely
fucking alarming.
Yeah.
Like,
like you don't want to,
you don't want to go around a corner,
you don't want to do anything and you
know,
like when you watch on the Monitor,
it's just the Monitor.
There's shit behind you that you're not
seeing unless you turn around and look.
So you hear a sound and be like,
I am not to.
I don't want to turn around.
I know that thing's going to be right in
my face and it's frightening.
What is the alien game for?
Is that for the vibe or.
Oculus is a Ridley Scott Alien.
Yeah,
that's the.
I think it's both because I had it for
Oculus.
It's fucking terrifying.
Alien something.
Yeah.
It's the one like alien.
The original movie.
Yeah.
You're on a ship.
It's a,
it starts with the doors open up and
that little thing,
drinking of the water.
That little chotchkies on the,
uh,
on the task and it's A.
Yeah,
it really gives a good to a recreation
of the,
of the movie,
which was fucking awesome.
That's one of the greatest one goes down
as one of my
favorite scene is also one of my
favorite examples when people talk about
pushing diversity and movies.
Oh yeah.
This movie had a female lead who is a
female superstar who a spoiler alert
winds up winning in the end,
but you don't need even notice now.
It never feels like it's crammed down
your throat.
Right.
As the last star wars,
it was like,
get the fuck out of here,
Laura dern.
You're not running the empire here.
You're like,
what is this?
Like?
She's the head General and then Carrie
Fisher's the other head general,
and I'm telling these men to shut up and
this all makes sense to you.
Is in that fucking amazing.
They had a,
that was 1979 and they had more of an
idea of how to present that then.
Uh,
yeah.
First of all,
sigourney weaver's just a fucking bad
ass believable movies.
Believe that she pulled it together.
She was such a great actress.
So that's alien if this ascent,
like,
that thing that you did at Disney
though.
Oh,
go to free roaming vr came out earlier
this year in orange,
California and exactly that would jamie
and I talked about that many times.
Like
that's the future,
like a warehouse,
like this space out here,
but converted into a giant vr
experience.
Yeah.
Whereas Orange California on from here,
look at that and we need to go to him.
When I first saw alien,
I'm back.
Uh,
you know,
kids.
I saw it in the movie theater when it
first came out there,
kids sat.
My mom took me.
It was 79.
Yeah.
And it was a leap.
It was just one of those movies that at
the time everyone goes,
oh my God,
you got to see this,
that the chest fucking burst scene just
slayed people.
Uh,
but yeah,
w w when you watch them that,
because traditional movies,
the guys the hero and that's what
happens when Tom Skerritt gets it.
You're just like,
wait,
why are they just killed the star,
the hero that was,
it was Tom Skerritt.
Yeah.
As like not his bucket moves a big movie
star.
Yeah.
And then I think it was like the first
movie where the spaceship was kind of a
truck and it was just dirty and just
regular guys concerned about getting
paid and,
and shit like that.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's why it was amazing.
Which is this one?
This is a covenant in Utero that came up
a year or two ago.
Cool.
Oh,
so this is after the covenant movie,
which is a fucking awesome one.
That's recent one.
I love movies I love.
They're so good.
I like that shit.
That movie.
They nailed it.
It was just great.
It didn't matter if a woman was running
and it was,
they weren't shoving it down your
throat.
No.
Whereas I felt like that last star wars
one with Laura Dern and Carrie Fisher
was like flying,
flying.
Carrie Fisher.
Come on.
Yeah,
I stopped.
I wasn't feeling it.
I didn't feel like they were.
Look,
there's certain women like,
um,
what is her name from house of cards?
The,
the,
the head woman Watson.
Jenny from Jenny from Sean Penn.
Penn.
So it's something,
something,
something Penn fuck's her name.
I think she used that to.
I'm embarraSsed,
right robin?
Round robin,
right?
Robin wright.
Okay.
Robin wright was playing a general.
I believe it.
Yeah,
bitch.
Right.
She could,
she could send in some fucking tanks,
I believe.
I believe that she would like the
planet.
I'd buy that.
Right.
But uh,
carrie fisher and laura dern,
I was like,
come on,
I see what you're doing.
They're running things.
I,
I think they've,
uh,
they just,
they're putting out too many star wars
movies to have that mystique and that
kind of a atmosphere that it was like to
go to one of them years ago.
It's also,
it's,
it's disney now.
Yeah.
Which is great because it's consistent
and it's good.
Right.
But it's never stunning.
It's terrifying.
It's never.
It's never x mokena.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
it's never fucked up.
Like when you leave the theater going,
holy shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
Can't do that anymore.
They kind of polish off the sharp edges
and sued the experience down to a
palatable mainstream appeal that first,
the first star wars back in [inaudible]
77 again.
I saw that in a movie theater with my
uncle.
My uncle joe took me and I didn't know
stores from a home of wall.
I remember the trailer playing on tv and
I was like,
all right,
that seems kind of cool.
Uh,
and then we sit down and that opening
scene with the giant ship just does a
fly over.
And I was just,
from that point on,
I was just mesmerized with this.
The illusion of size that they got in
the ship and it was an old school ship.
The added out of like plastic model of
practical effects.
It was all like models,
like they went and bought like a bunch
of different.
You remember those old bottles that we
used to do like cars and oem.
Remember those glue them together.
You get the bottle glue,
rIght?
I used to love those.
Yeah.
They took a bunch of parts from those
things and built the millennium falcon.
They built those battleships from like
parts and you can kind of tell because
they're so weird and eclectic and some
of the parts don't seem to match.
Worked.
It totally worked.
Yeah.
That was a.
You know,
if you.
You didn't imagine being in a,
in one of those x wing fighters as a
kid,
it was just an amazing thing that's
kinda gone.
It shows you how great alien like ridley
scott alien really was because all those
star wars was a great movie.
Honestly,
star wars doesn't really hold up
[inaudible] like if you watch it today,
you look at the special effects,
like what?
What am I watching this clunky and,
and then the catena scenes and I that.
Yeah.
That's always.
The mouths don't move like the monster
phases.
Like,
it's weird if they're wearing a mask,
it's really obvious,
but then you go just two yeaRs later to
ridley scott alien,
that motherfucker holds up today.
It looks amazing.
You know,
I got yelled at because I've watched it
with my kids because my 10 year old can
handle shit.
My eight year old cannot.
Oh man,
I,
I watched it.
I'm like,
you think you can handle it?
And they'Re like,
yeah,
I can handle it.
okay.
I'm going to die the first time.
The dude got the tongue to the forehead.
What?
Watching daddy night maRes bill.
Remember that?
Yeah,
my dad,
my mom and my dad took me,
my brother and my sister when I was
seven years old to go see bonnie and
clyde with a warren beatty.
And uh,
what's her name there?
I can't remember who played by faye
dunaway.
Very good.
Thank you.
Yes.
And uh,
now it's famous for being one of the
most graphic
machine gunning at the end of the movie.
I mean they were pulling up.
They got ambushed by law and uh,
they just get shot up the whole movie
though as a seven year old kid.
I liked these people.
They were funny.
They've robbed banks and stuff,
but you know,
they,
they'd make jokes and they were coal and
you've got to know him as a person.
So as a seven year old I was like,
oh,
these,
these people are cool.
So then the end of the movie comes and,
and they're out there and you hear the
birds fly away and clyde looks at
bonnie,
uh,
with,
one lens missing from his,
his glasses and it's really quiet and
then all hell breaks loose.
It's just five guys shooting thompson's
at both of them and they're being
riddled with bullet holes and the scene
goes on and they're falling down and
against the car.
The car is just full.
Yeah,
there it is.
It's,
it's so brutal.
It's crazy to seeing the girl get it.
Oh yeah.
Something ruthless about seeing a girl
gets shot a hundred times.
Yeah.
Look at her.
It was,
I,
I'm that.
We saw this at the drive in and uh,
I,
I started vomiting in the car seven
years old.
We had,
we had been to arby's before,
so,
uh,
my rbs was all over the car.
I was screaming,
crying and throwing up,
going like,
what the fuck did you take me to say I
liked these people.
I had like a to our relationship with
them and it ends like that.
I was horrified.
Horrified.
As a kid.
Yeah.
There's certain things,
but is that bad?
Like ultimately you saw that when you
weRe a kid,
like maybe,
maybe it's maybe it's not good to shield
kids from too much.
Maybe not to that extent.
Show me a cartoon first or something
because I dunno,
I dunno if it affected me.
It's hard to tell Without knowing what
it would be like if I didn't see stuff
like that.
Uh,
but the fact that I remember it vividly
so many years later
maybe had an effect,
but yeah,
but it isn't a negative effect.
There's certain experiences that you
want,
you can have,
like today as an adult,
you could see a movie where a guy gets
shot and you can handle.
It dOesn't freak you out.
Of course,
if you saw it when you were four,
you'd probably freak out.
Yeah.
But is it good to expeRience that when
you're four just so that you know,
it's a thing and you have a different
view of the world or is it good like
you're not a parent,
but as a parent,
this is the age old question.
Like hoW much do you protect your kids
and how much do you let them break their
arm?
Because you break your arm,
you know,
if you fall,
you break your arm.
If everybody's like helicopter
parenting,
you constantly like,
I don't want anybody to die,
but I don't mind if anybody gets banged
up a little bit.
Right.
Thank you.
Should I think you should know that if
you trip it hurts.
You know there's.
And there's also,
you should know that bullets are real.
This is a real thing that happens.
like with my kids,
ever since my kids have been really
little,
I've been hunting and so I've been
bringing home meat and explaining to
them that this is meat from an animal
that I shot.
If you go to the supermarket and you buy
a steak that came from an animal and I
try to get this in their head at a early
age,
so then I introduced them to watching a
hunting show with me where we shot a
deer and then took the deer apart.
Polshek shake you seeing like they're
watching us cut an elca part.
My kids watching this and I'm like,
well this is where you get meat.
Like when we eat dinner,
if we eat elk for dinner,
this is exactly where it came from.
I shot it in the mountains.
We cut it up.
We packed it out on our back.
We put it into a truck.
We drove somewhere and now we're here.
Now we're eating it.
This is a.
Yeah.
I guess if you present it like that,
that's I would guess is a good thing
maybe.
But there's something weird about
watching a little kid watching animal
gets shot where like,
uh,
yeah,
they realized my dad and that is that
good?
Is my debt a piece of shit?
These animals are so beautiful.
Well,
animals aRe hot dog.
Your hot dogs a fucking that you want a
hot dog,
right?
Yeah.
And that'S an animal like,
okay.
Like,
because most kids just,
it's a hot dog.
It's the.
Yeah.
It's not an actual animal.
They kind of know,
like if you asked a little kid,
hey,
we're this cheeseburger came from,
oh it's from a cow.
But that's like,
damn.
That's like saying the moon is a one,
six earth's gravity.
I know that.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No real.
I don't have a real chance apply it to
anything.
so yeah.
So when do you show your kids?
Like,
like there's a lot of videos that I
watch while close my laptop and the kids
come in,
they're like violent videos.
So yeah,
especially like animals.
Like I was watching this video of these
hyenas tearing apart this gazelle.
Oh,
fucking horrific.
the ripping the guts out.
Oh,
yanking on the guts and this thing is
making these weird noises like home and
chunks of its guts out.
Oh my god,
fuck,
fuck.
And then my,
you know,
my lIttle girl comes over and slammed it
and she's like,
what are you watching?
And I'm watching the hyena rip apart
gazelles guts.
She's like,
oh,
okay.
I don't want to say all right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
but,
but kind of what's the difference
between that and showing you hunting?
like is there a.
I'm doing a quick.
That's one difference.
When I shoot an animal,
if I shoot an animal with a bow,
it's dead in seconds.
Yeah.
You know,
with a well placed shot,
it's not going anywhere.
It's like the last elk I shot,
that one that's right out there on the
floor in front of the werewolf.
That thing died in five yards,
five yards,
tipped over,
feet up in the air,
got shot.
Her rIght in the heart was perfect shot.
So it was,
it was almost instantaneous death.
Yes,
it might've lived 15,
20 seconds and that was it.
People.
Uh,
I don't.
People don't seem
to be shocked that much anymore.
I know you're trying to keep it from
your kids and things like that obviously
makes sense,
but it's almost impossible to keep some
really horrific shit from people,
especially if you give your kid a phone.
Yeah,
yeah.
You're giving them access to a lot of
nasty stuff.
And like I remember when I was a kid,
the,
the big thing was like faces of death.
You want to go get faces a death man,
we'll watch it.
It's crazy guys.
They beat up a monkey and cut his head
off and eat the brains and everything.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's kind of fake.
And you could tell the stage things and
I think the only real stuff was a like
news footage of airline disasters and
accidents.
And so that was one that was real where
these,
uh,
these guys,
somewhere in the middle east tied these
guys arms to one car and his legs to it
and they pulled them apart.
I cannot watch that shit.
It's terrible.
And now in stunning hd,
you can see in a snuff films years ago
was kind of an urban myth,
you know,
it was a thing,
now they're readily available to anybody
in a matter of seconds and I don't know
what kind of effect that has on people
and,
and maybe society.
But uh,
and there's really nothIng you could do
pandora's out.
So I think it's affecting people though.
Oh,
it's definitely sensitizing.
That's the argument about video games as
well,
right?
yeah.
We're seeing so much violence in
committing violence in video games.
Like,
uh,
jamie,
what was that video game where,
uh,
the guy got in trouble because he made a
video of him torturing some as in
redmond he punched,
he punched a.
I'm a woman in the face that was a
pRotesting for,
um,
women's rights,
women's rights to vote suffrage.
And uh,
and he got in trouBle because he posted
it and it,
yeah,
it was like a violent thing against
women.
But it's a thing you can do in the game,
right?
Like they made it in the game.
So you Could do that on purpose.
And once it became viral,
people started going up to her in the
game and doing even more terrible than
there's one where a guy ropes her hog
ties or throws her on the back oF the
horse,
rides her to a swamp and throws her to
an aLligator which then eats her and the
swamp.
That is so crazy that you can do that.
If the allegation unbelievable the
alligator will eat.
And it's not even a thing like,
hey,
do this.
It's just part of the game that they
said,
well,
if people want to do it,
It's a very open ended game.
Rockstar went bullshit with this game.
It's amazing.
Does,
does it always happen the exact same way
or do you throw rocks in the water and
the alligator has a different way of.
Yeah,
there are different animations for the
same thing.
So,
and different.
Actually there was one,
uh,
you'll be riding next to a guy that
you're supposed to ride somewhere with.
And I'm,
the guy says something like,
all right,
we're almost there or something.
And,
and if you're far away from the guy,
he yells it,
alright,
we're almost there.
And if he's right next to you,
he goes,
well,
we're almost there like the guy,
the voice actor,
how to do a shitload of takes based on
what the animation is.
So I did the voiceover for the ufc game,
right.
Took for ever forever.
You're there for days and days and days,
readIng every single variation of a head
kick to an arm bar to a take down to
ground and pound to tko stoppage to
kicking someone in the nuts like
everything.
and someone's got to fucking put that
together.
And then it's got to be coded where it
plays at the right time.
It really is amazing.
Yeah,
it's god damn amazing.
I,
um,
but red,
red dead's like really insane.
Is this it?
There's a,
what is this?
This is the.
Yeah,
this is a guy.
Oh,
this guy just smoking a cigar.
So it's so funny.
The things that go on in this game,
the ability to kill people.
I had a Louis J.
Gomez on the show and he,
he plays this and uh,
he,
there's like a morality direction you
could take.
You could either be a good guy or bad
guy,
really good,
really bad,
and it will affect how the course of the
game and and whether you're wanted,
whether people are nice to you.
Real.
Yeah.
Like you could do a favor for somebody.
You'd be riding somewhere and someone
will go,
please,
could you help me ouT?
Just a women's rights activist.
Not hurt,
but he's going to throw this lady off of
the mountain and this is just some guy
online has done this.
This is the same youtube he does.
He's got a lot of videos.
Oh jeez.
He fell.
He fell himself.
He was trying to kick her off and oh ha
ha.
But a and louis apparently would kill
everybody.
He killed a guy's dog and skinned it in
front of him and then shot him in the
face.
Like,
that's really neat.
That's really neat.
Dog in front of the guy and the guy's
just like crying.
It's brutal.
I mean,
do you thInk that most politicians,
are those people looking for outrageous?
Just not aware of this yet?
yeah,
absolutely.
Not.
Years ago they were kind of like,
well,
this must be violent video games,
and it was so funny because like 10
years after doom,
like they're showing doom on tv.
Like,
oh,
that's the bad video game.
I was like,
jesus christ,
that's nothing.
What are you talking about?
And now like,
uh,
like I said at datto,
same guys.
Yeah.
joe gta.
I did some of the voices in gta five.
It was fucking hilarious.
So I know.
Yeah,
to do that.
I sang some of the uh,
promotional songs for the beer piss
watser beer.
It was great.
I know laszlo,
who does all the sound for the,
uh,
the games.
But uh,
this thing sold like $750,
million dollars in the first three days
that came out.
What happens if you bring a black man to
the kkk?
They have fucking kkk,
rally planned,
rally going on and there's a part of the
game where you have to infiltrate what
happens when you bring a black guy at
different happened really the clan,
they don't freak out.
Not,
not in particular,
but the job.
I think the mission here is to just kill
all the klan guys.
It's not like you join up and I'll have
a good time.
It would be more realistic is if you
brought a black guy to the clan,
mean they tried to kill the black guy.
Right?
Right.
But that would be real.
That would be crazy.
There are some weird parts in it where
they're very misogynistic because it's
supposed to be like 1899 or something
and it's very misogynistic.
And then there's some race references
that they make that are kind of like,
oof,
oof.
wow.
That's bold.
Like what,
what do they say about black guy?
Like they'll call them boy in some of
the,
uh,
when,
when a guy like a non player character
will pass by and be kind of nasty and
uh,
they never presented in a good way.
It's not like,
you know,
oh,
cool,
this guy's great.
Uh,
it's always some scumbag.
A character.
Yeah.
I love him.
It's like the last frontier for chaos
right now.
Yeah,
it really is.
And I think because there's such a lack
of awareness on the part of a lot of
people,
like I,
I get games the day they come and
actually before I get alpha testing,
beta testing,
I'm playing the games months before they
come out.
Really?
Yeah.
I love it.
I get it on that.
Uh,
you sign up for a,
uh,
the ultimate package on origin or steam
and you get access to the games when
they,
when they're testing them.
Mostly just pay.
Yeah.
It's a pay thing.
Obviously they want to make some,
some money and I want to play.
The games are really busting your report
bugs and things on.
Yeah.
If you just play,
they automatically kind of have
something in place that will let them
know if there's a problem or you can
email them and say,
hey there,
you know,
I died and I'm stuck in a rock now up to
my waist.
Have you ever talked to some of the
people that make those things?
Do you ever have them on your show?
Laszlo works at rockstar.
He's a sound engineer guy.
He records all the sound,
but he's involved in every aspect of all
those games from the beginning of grand
theft auto,
the first red dead redemption two.
Um,
and uh,
it's amazing.
I've been to rockstar in New York and
took a tour of the place and it's just a
bunch of fucking nerds sitting around.
They have a day where,
you know,
you can bring your dogs in and it's all
wide open.
No cubicles or anything.
The guys that run it are these english
guys and they're brilliant or New
Zealand or something.
They have that accent sense.
One of those weird accents that you
can't tell where it's from work insane
hours.
Yeah,
that's it.
They are dedicated like a game,
like,
like a rockstar game,
gta or that.
It's so above other games,
like,
like you can't even.
I played some shitty games where I
download it.
I stopped playing and within five
minutes I'm like,
fuck,
this sucks.
Like it just,
you know,
it sucks.
Right.
And rockstar games or just,
you know,
it sounds like I'm doing a spot for him,
but uh,
they're so above everything else.
The animation,
the,
the sandbox quality where you're able to
just run around and do shit like that's
an appeal that I don't like feeling like
they're on a track in a game and a
certain games are like that,
like a call of duty is very track based,
you know,
you play online a lot against other
people.
They're small maps,
but a game like that you could just go
off if you want to.
You could just spend time fishing.
Like you could just get tackle and go to
a lake and fish and catch fish.
You catch fish.
It's a.
Yeah,
you can just spend eight hours just
catching fish,
just fishing,
hunting.
You could go out and hunt.
I've heard that you track like the bear
and,
and that motherfucker can you saw like
can get you a.
I love games like that though.
I love open ended games.
I always liked that shit.
Even when I was um,
back in the eighties,
uh,
my cousin got a atari 800 computer and
it had a cartridge for a game called
star raiders.
And this was right after star wars came
out.
And I was fascinated because it wasn't
just a joystick and a button that you
got on an arcade game,
it was you used the keyboard like for
warp drive or you had a dock with a
space station at one point and you're
going in orbit around a planet.
LIke there was all these things that you
used the keyboard for.
And I thought that was amazing.
Like I don't like just a running gun
type thing.
I like being able to use a lot of
different keys and have a lot of
options.
How much time do you spend playing video
games?
Because I'm getting the impression it's
insane.
There have been days where I have a
weekends or something where I have
played from maybe 2:00
PM till 3:00
AM,
like 12,
13 hours of playing it.
It's no eating.
Yeah.
I'll,
I'll eat a little snack,
a little snack.
I'll order something or miss.
You'll make something.
She's playing viDeo games like I'll be
playing on the computer and that's in
front of me on the table I was talking
about in the living room.
And then on the big screen tv,
which is in front of me on the wall,
she sitting in like a folding chair with
a tv tray playing red dead redemption on
the xbox.
So occasionally look back and go,
oh,
you got to see this great kills a video,
a funny video of a couple engaging in
virtual reality and they're having sex
and the girls blowing the guy.
And then the video,
joeY diaz comes in the room.
That's hilarious.
There was a.
Well there is vr porn.
Have You checked that out?
I haven't.
It's really interesting there.
There is.
There is some that is pretty amazing.
Like a girl Will come up like you're
laying on your back and a girl is in the
room.
She takes her clothes off and comes up
on you and gets right by your ear and
whisper something and,
and you hear it,
you almost feel the breath on you.
It's that fucking crazy.
And,
and you,
you feel like you can reach and touch,
but you know,
there's no one there.
But.
And again,
you can't even get close to showing what
it's like on a regular flat screen,
but when you put that in,
it's a real space.
It's three d and they look pretty real
aside from the resolution difference
because when you,
when you magnify something that close to
your eyes,
the pixels get bigger too.
So it's not quite there.
But you could see where that's going.
You get that.
And one of those fucking flashlights.
I used a really early,
really early version of the htc vive
many years ago.
duncan had one,
my friend duncan trussell had one in his
house and it was really pixelated and it
was very strange.
It was just a real simple game and it
was real blocky looking.
It looked like like old doom or
something like that.
But it was in complete three dimensions.
And so I was looking up and looking all
around.
I was like,
wow,
this is kind of crazy.
And then I went back to his place like
two years later and there had been a
gigantic leap and them.
And now the leap is sort of balanced
out.
It's not,
it hasn't gotten that much better.
Yeah.
Right yet.
There are a few games that I love
playing on the oculus because it's like
flying games are incredible.
Um,
and if you have a Really good system
with a duel 10,
80 ti I graphics cards,
one of them is insane to have and my
assistant has two of them and so I could
run everything on ultrasound.
Do you prefer videos on a computer?
Yeah,
yeah,
I,
I prefer a pc,
But I'll play on xbox and stuff.
Uh,
it's pretty cool.
I'm terrible with a controller.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
So mouse and a keyboard is so much more
precise.
I got a.
Yeah.
I always say I,
if anyone ever argues,
I go,
I've never missed a folder on my
desktop.
I've never gone,
oh shit,
I missed it.
But there's something called a,
an ap zim apex that you plug into an
xbox or playstation and then plug
keyboard mouse into it.
You're runnIng on xbox with a keyboard
and mouse.
So.
And it's so good.
I destroy people,
uh,
when I play on that because it's more
accurate,
so much more accuracy and you're just
quick reflexes and yeah,
from the online video game days of the
early two thousands and the nineties,
like it was always.
Yeah.
Mouse and keyboard was,
was It a console was for babies?
They weren't good back then.
Now curious.
He was terrible.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
when I play some of the,
um,
like combat flying games,
they have things now that are,
you look like you're in the cockpit of a
plane.
All the gauges work.
They have reflectIons of light coming
through.
I mean the ground looks amazing.
And in vr when you pull the stick back
and turn,
because I use a joy stick and throttle.
It's,
it's amazing.
Uh,
you can look over your shoulder and now
you're seeing your wing and the ground
and you're pulling back and you get
dizzy.
Like you get so fucking dizzy and
crashes are startling.
Like like if you lose control and you
plow into the ground,
you kind of jump because it's,
you're just,
it's,
I think it's that primal part of your
head going,
like accepting what it's seeing.
I wonder if there would be a really good
way to learn how to fly.
I would imagine it would be that guy
that stole that plane up in portland
recently slammed into the.
Yeah,
killed himself.
He said he learned how to fly on a
simulator flight simulator.
Microsoft flight simulator x is like
unbelievable.
And he was doing like loop de loops in
the sky and shit.
He's like,
let's see if we could do a loop.
And he was saying I'm going to kill
myself,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He's like,
yeah,
I think uh,
I'll do a,
I'll try to do a loop and then knows it
in and call it a day what a maniac.
But the fact that he could get access
and take off like that is kind of scary.
Whoops.
We all think,
uh,
you know,
everything so secure.
Then when we thought there were like
missiles on the roof of the white house
and the pentagon and stuff,
and then after nine,
11 and I.
Yeah,
I guess not.
I guess that was all bullshit.
The actual pentagon got hit by a fucking
plane,
although now you're going to get a lot
of people writing this play,
bro was.
It was a mitchell.
Everyone knows it.
You're a gatekeeper.
You're a shill,
a shill for the eu.
Um,
it doesn't,
uh,
who,
who does your show?
That is a flat earth or eddie bravo.
Eddie bravo.
That's it.
I don't know if he's still a flutter.
You might've abandoned.
He might've moved on.
Let me think that still he thought the
earth is a disk.
Maybe he said,
I think I don't want to misinterpret
what he's saying.
I don't want to misrepresent.
I think he was saying he doesn't know,
but he doesn't believe nasa because it's
only someone's word over history and he
likes that.
He thinks it's fun.
He just conspiracies.
Okay,
well they are.
Yeah,
they are kind of fun.
But that flat earth one I realized I was
arguing with flat earthers on twitter
and that's when I really started going
like,
what,
what am I doing?
What am I doing?
Why am I engaging that debt is like the
dumbest version of I know you are,
but what am I for the rest of time?
Yes.
So stupid.
That argument is,
it's a it,
it's crazy.
I was talking,
I was arguing with somebody and then I
had my show to do and I'm neil degrasse
tyson was taping his show in my studio
before I came on.
So he was in the lobby when I was in our
greenroom when,
when I was on and I started talking
about it and I go,
you know,
let's get someone in here.
Maybe that might have a,
an opinion on this.
Neil degrasse tyson coming.
And apparently he gets shit all the time
from flat earthers saying that it's,
you know,
he's full of shit.
No,
it all started off as a goof.
It had to just like everything else.
But it started off on four.
Chan did it like free bleeding.
Yes,
exactly.
Which is hilarious.
People explain that to people don't know
free bleeding is a woMan's rights thing
and it's a instead of using a tampon
during their period or a pad,
they just bleed through their pants and
show it proudly that they will walk
around bleeding and it was never real.
It was neveR a real thing and then
people saw it and thought it was real.
Like they.
They put it out there for chan and
people actually believed and know not
just believed it started.
He started doing it.
Yes.
They started doing it for real.
They turned it into something women's
rights,
badge of honor to have a pair of white
pants on with a giant patch of a
brownish red in the center.
It's insane.
It's crazY.
It just shows you how easily manipulated
people are.
Things that happen like that.
UnfortunatelY it turned out to be goofs.
They start out as goofs.
Yeah.
You know,
and then they wIll listen.
We were talking about this last song was
with you,
right?
The proud boys.
Gavin off as a goof and then became
like,
what the money.
They won't let them in Australia now if
you've seen that.
No,
it's,
it's gotten insane.
Yeah.
Like gavin is considered a,
like a war criminal at this point.
Uh,
I know gavin very well.
He used to be on compound media,
my,
my network.
Um,
and that's where the whole thing started
and just explain how it all started
because people don't know.
It's,
it's amazing when you think about it
because it makes you question
everything.
Like how did,
how did a nazi Germany stock,
was that a joke?
Was that like stalin,
ism and everything?
Uh,
in Russia.
Gavin,
I had a show.
Very outrageous.
Gavin is one of these.
Just a funny,
outrageous guy.
His whole career has been based on
satire and parody and lots of
provocateur.
A provocateur.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Loves shaking.
People are to find out where he really.
Well,
how he really feels and when he's
playing games,
right.
It's very bLurry.
Absolutely.
So we have a,
we have this employee,
uh,
ben ratner,
little kid.
We,
we actually hired him just because his
name was ratner and we wanted to call
him rat,
like in fast times a rent.
Why don't you turn on the camera?
Uh,
so it was,
it was great.
Uh,
he rat never talked about girls.
It's like this really jewish real red
hair kind of gangly kid.
And uh,
he,
he liked going to broadway shows and
things and we always questioned his
sexuality and whatnot.
And gavin really started hitting on him
going,
what are you doing?
Like get laid a kid,
your age should be out there,
you just fucking plowing through pussy.
and he's like,
I'm waiting for the right girl and
everything.
So gavin would continuously goof on him.
So he,
He would alwayS go to broadway plays.
So gavin started getting a music from
musicals and playing it to him like,
hey,
look at this,
you pussy,
you know,
is this what you like?
Uh,
and one of them was proud of your boy.
It's a broadwaY,
a song from a musical,
a disney musical,
I believe.
And it's celia.
Oh,
proud of your boy.
It's one of those big grandiose broadway
pieces of shit.
Can't stand that stuff man.
I hate it.
oh,
it is,
it's terrible.
Uh,
so he goofed on about that and then said
we ought to make a club called the proud
boys and that way you can learn how to
be a man and you know,
you,
you'll get checks and tattoos and,
you know,
drink beer and hang out with guys as a
joke.
IT was like this parody of a men's club
and so over the top that it was like,
I think part of the way to get beaten
into this gang,
this club was that you had to recite
five breakfast cereals while the other
members punched you and,
and they would keep punching you until
you spit a soul.
Ludicrous.
So ridiculous.
Such parody.
Uh,
and slowly this fucking thing mutated
into some.
It got more members.
Uh,
they started wearing one of those
shirts,
the with the yellow car Piping on the
collar and stuff.
it's a specific shirt that became the
uniform,
perry ellis perry ellis shirts,
a specific black shirt with gold piping
and uh,
on the collar and,
and the,
uh,
the sleeves.
And that became like the uniform.
And because it was presented as a
chauvinist club,
like,
like girls are allowed,
minorities are allowed,
it doesn't matter who you are,
but in essence it is a guy thing and we
will talk shit about girls and we're
going to drink and get laid.
And it was just a men thing.
So they started getting together at
bars,
you know,
in the area in manhattan.
And how is this organized?
It's organized through his compound
media show,
the compound media show,
his own twitter account,
and an facebook,
which he subsequently lost.
He's persona non grata on social media,
but that's how it started.
And it never was supposed to go any
further than that.
Gavin himself didn't really take it any
It's just,
let's get together every so often we
have a good time.
We drink,
laugh,
everything like that.
Well then this whole thing with politics
got involved because antifa,
which antifascist started,
uh,
coming into a conservatives that wanted
to speak.
So gavin was conservative as
conservative.
He'd get speaking engagements at
schools,
nyu or,
um,
any,
uh,
numerous places around New York city and
antifa would show up to protest him and
try to shut down the event.
So then the proud boys would go and
protect gavin so he wouldn't get harmed
doing these speaking engagements and
that.
So then it turned into this because
they're fighting with antifa.
They must be the fall,
the fascists,
nazis.
Um,
and once that gets out there,
there's no pulling it back.
You could try to explain how you're not
a nazi till you're blue in the face.
It ain't going away.
And especially because it's a good
story.
The press likes it.
It's this good versus evil thing.
They present antifa.
I like their protest.
They always call them and the protesters
were beaten.
Their fucking violent,
violent group of people that are there
to,
to hit people they don't agree with and
silence people that want to speak.
And that's exactly what happened with
gavin and ann coulter and milo
yiannopoulos,
uh,
a ben shapiro,
the,
a lot of these conservative people can't
go to these venues and speak.
They get shut down because of a violent
group of people called antifa.
So proud boys were kind of the answer to
that.
So gavin can go around and actually,
uh,
speak.
Well when that happened,
more people came on board because they
kind of liked to beat people up.
When you have a gang,
a group of people,
and one of their missions is now to beat
up people you don't agree with
politically.
When there was there,
there's tiers to the membership.
Like the highest tier was you fought for
the cause to actually get into a
fistfight.
Yeah.
Yes.
I'm sure gavin thought was like,
I've talked to gavin.
I'd like gavin,
I've had gavin on the podcasts and the
last time I had them on I didn't know
what this whole thing was.
And so he was explaining the proud boys
and he was talking to me about,
we're going to punch them.
We're going to punch people.
Yeah.
I was like,
whoa,
whoa.
And I was like,
did you know you can't just punch people
like they,
they punched back and then you get mad
that you punched them in and they shoot
you when you get out of your car.
This escalates.
People don't just take it.
Well,
it was never supposed to be an offensive
punching.
Uh,
when,
when I would speak to gavin and every
example I would see it was an answer to
violence.
They,
they would have violence perpetrated on
them.
Proper context.
And all bald needed to say is he's
calling for violence.
That's it.
And that's what they've said about gavin
over and over again,
taking things out of context and use it
as a gamble.
The other problem being that the antifa
people are a lot of skinny dudes and
chicks with masks on and they
that adept at fighting.
There's a horrible video of this one
antifa guy tries to hit someone with it
looks like some kind of a stick or a
pipe.
Yeah.
And the guy it and fucking
blasted him on the chin and fucking put
him down.
His head bounces off the concrete
unconscious,
which is a whole lot of people die.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
That's how people die in fights like,
oh,
he killed them with his bare hands.
Yeah.
He hit his fucking head on.
He hit his head on the concrete.
You got hit by the world.
Literally the world,
right?
Right.
Gravity.
The budge it.
Gravity has punched you in the back of
the head.
So yes,
these people have this idea that they're
going to go places.
They're going to shut everybody down and
because they're in a group,
you're going to scream and yell and hit
people with bike locks and all this
stuff that y'all seen.
Weird thing is that that's from the
left.
That was never from the left before.
When I was a kid.
I grew up when I was eight,
from eight slash seven slash 11 during
the Vietnam war.
I lived in san francisco and I was
around the real hippies and I remember
being a little kid.
I remember that moment of times like a
flower children.
I mean,
they were the hippies and the lefties
were were love and peace and no violence
and everyone was doing acid and now
they're all on adderall and they're
hitting people with bike locks.
It was,
yeah,
it's a different thing.
There was a time where the liberals,
the hippies,
the,
you know,
they were the ones that when there would
be a demonstration and the national
guard would show up,
they'd be putting flowers in.
The barrels of the guns are famous
pictures of that,
and then kent state was a bunch of
hippies literally getting shot by the
national guard,
the national guard that has completely
flipped around.
It's the weirdest thing and I don't know
how it got distinguished.
We're proud boys became this evil group
of people and an antifa is the good
group of people.
Now I understand that.
Proud boy,
a proud boys were infiltrated by white
nationalist,
nazi,
white supremacist,
whatever it is,
but those were constantly being
disavowed by gavin.
Gavin never wanted any of that
happening,
but is there a way.
How do you get in though?
Here's the question,
because this is my.
You saw my last comedy special.
This is my criticism of a vegans is not
that there's anything wrong with being a
vegan,
is that when you have a group where
anybody can join,
you're going to get a certain amount of
fucking idiots.
If you have a million people for sure
you have 100,000
fucking idiots.
There's no getting around that.
Yeah,
so if you have a group where anybody can
join and you have a million people in
that group,
you're going to have 100,000
fucking fucking idiots and those people
are going to define your group.
The worst behavior in that group is
where people are going to call too as an
example.
That's it.
I think this is also a symptom of the
social media era today,
especially with twitter because you
can't express yourself and explain
things 140 or 280 characters.
It just takes too much time so they can
say,
oh,
proud boys,
racist scumbag nazi gavin,
and they'll always racist gum back nazi.
Then all of a sudden that's the
narrative and everybody keeps pushing it
and the videos of people punching
little skinny people.
Oh,
look at these people.
They beat up the antifa,
these fucking assholes,
and gavin's an asshole.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what it comes down to.
I've seen it presented a.
Well.
You ask how it starts and how it grows
and how you become a member by buying a
fucking shirt,
by buying a perry ellis shirt and
opening a chapter to their chapters
worldwide.
You see it.
It's like,
here's the,
the proud boys Australia.
Here's the properties.
England proud boys,
fucking Japan,
like it's everywhere and it never was
supposed to get to that point and
regardless of how these people act,
it now reflects on gavin.
Even though he wanted to hang out in a
bar with a few people do is public
speaking without being hassled.
And that's it.
And,
and I see the way the media manipulates
things.
I've been party to it myself and I've
seen gavin presented in photos where you
look and go,
holy fuck.
It's hitler.
Liked like they get them.
There's one picture,
gavin,
that I was petrified by.
He's got his arms folded,
he's got a scowl on his face,
that hair,
you know,
the short on the side,
long on the top and he's looking like,
like he's angry and I'm like that,
that stuff.
The guy that him and his wife who is
american indian by the way,
his wife is american indian.
He's got beautiful kids that come over
my house and use the pool and we hang
out and barbecue.
I'm like,
that's not that guy.
No one knows that guy from the paper.
They're getting this impression.
He's a really nice guy.
He's.
He's a generous.
Just a really cool guy to hang out with
and what you see them do in the media is
just crazy.
Especially when you know he didn't
invent some goddamn nazi group.
He was just trying to have a little
outrageous fun and it ran from him.
It got away from the origin of it
though.
The way you're describing that is
fucking fantastic.
Isn't that nuts?
It's crazy that that is what presented
it.
I mean that,
that emerged out of that.
We,
we,
we fuck with rat all the time.
[inaudible] we go.
Can you believe the inspiration for the
proud boys?
Is this little jewish?
Where is that guy?
Photo of online.
He.
Oh,
I'm sure there is rat compound media
rat.
You'll probably find them.
Uh,
it's.
How much does this weird you out though?
That compound media was the source of
all this is weird.
Like,
and it's one of those things you worry
about like,
like I don't want to then be taught
because I know how it works.
I love gavin,
but I don't want to be tied to the proud
boys at this point.
You know,
I got my own fucking problems through
history.
I don't need any more piled on me.
But what was that thing that I'd sent
you?
That.
There he is.
That's a rat.
I guess that was halloween.
Okay.
You,
what's this?
I was wearing a suit that was,
I was the mayor from jaws.
Mayor von.
I was for halloween.
That's awesome.
That's the guy that the proud boys.
The proud boys got 1938 propaganda
posters.
LIttle cutie isn't a norman rockwell
painting.
That's it.
He should be there with like a guy who's
handing them an apple pie.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's the face of the new nazi
movement.
I think that there's a lot of mistakes
were made,
but gavin's gavin's made some mistakes
and like his,
his whole thing of,
of,
of blurring the lines between parody and
honesty.
It's.
He thinks it's fun.
It's very punk rock.
Like he came up last time.
He's on the podcast,
which is a few years back.
He came on dressed like Michael Douglas
from falling down.
He had a briefcase.
He brought the suit,
like the short sleeve shirts like that
all the time now.
Like he goes around I,
I just,
I just did a skype interview with him
yesterday,
two days ago from the hotel room.
And he.
Yeah,
he's got the pocket protector and the
pens and the glasses.
Yeah,
like falling down.
He thinks it's funny,
but people need to understand.
And this is true.
He is the godfather of the hipsters.
Yeah.
He'll put in godfather of hipsters.
can google him,
he comes up,
all of that wardrobe the guys are
wearing.
They will.
They look like they're wearing old tiMey
suits with the skinny ties.
Gavin mcinnes literally started that
fashion trend in williamsburg and they.
It took off from there that the hipster
dress,
the way people would dress with those
weird mustaches and all that shit that
literally came out of gavin gavin,
which is amazing.
The motherfucker is.
He is a guy.
There's something like magnetic about
the guy.
He is what a cult leader is like.
He could Just start a cult,
which in essence by accident he did
between the hipsters and then this.
He's one of those guys like,
I like gavin,
why don't you start?
Why don't you start a cult where you get
to fuck the people's wives.
Like that kind of cult,
like why do you go with.
We also did some really good interviews
online where he would trIck these
leftists into sitting down with him in
interviews and then along the way there
we're having this conversation.
It would be exposed that he didn't agree
with them at all and they were trapped
like this hardcore feminist got trapped
with them.
A couple of other people get trapped in
this room with him and they,
they realized like halfway,
like some of the line of questioning and
the way he's approaching things.
So like,
oh my god,
he's an interesting guy.
He's very interesting.
And outside of this voice thing of you
never,
never invented that.
They never did any of that.
He would be doing great.
Yeah.
Although he had a problem with one of
one of his own companies that he made
after vice,
they bought them out of vice because uh,
shane turned more liberal and it wasn't
really,
they weren't really a meshing anymore
over their advice.
So they kind of just bought out a gavin.
He,
he got a lot of money,
decided to do his own thing.
He,
uh,
had an firm,
I guess
it was.
Yeah.
Uh,
and then he got the boot from that for
making a trans gender comments.
We'll use opinion on transgender people
have mental health,
mental health issue.
And he was brInging up all these.
Here's the problem.
He was,
he was saying some things that are
correct.
Yeah.
Interspersed with again,
yesterday and sarcasm in his mind.
This was like,
just,
this is something you can talk about
where it was in the public side,
particularly during the caitlyn jenner,
the whole thing.
people had decided the transgender was
amazing.
It's amazing,
it's beautiful.
She's incredible.
And he was saying,
no,
these are people that are menTally ill
and there's an a,
there's a website that he was pointing
to,
I think it's called transgender regrets
or something like that where they haVe
all these stories of all these men who
turned Into women and then turned back
to men again.
Now they don't have dicks.
No,
they have to take testosterone
injections and they hate their life.
And there's some of them who did it like
when they were in their sixties and now
now they're in their seventies and
trying to be a man again.
And,
and that gender dysphoria was thought to
be a mental health issue.
Like anorexia,
like a lot,
a lot of other.
There's body dysphoria,
but people have weird,
um,
you know,
a bodybuilders credit,
they,
they never think they're big enough.
You have like weird perceptions of their
physical presence in there and some,
uh,
I had a psychologist,
dr deborah,
so who was discussing late onset gender
dysphoria in autistic girls that
autistic teenage girls,
they don't feel like they fit in and
people can convince them that they're
actually a man.
Wow.
And so a lot of them start taking
hormones and,
and,
and going through transition,
massive regrets.
And then unfortunately for women,
when,
especially when you're a teenager and
you're going through puberty and you
take hormones,
you literally start developing male
features.
YoUr face gets harder and thicker and
wider.
Your shoulders get bigger,
like the whole deal.
Your hands.
Yeah.
Click gross.
the size of a thumb you.
So you make these irreversible changes
or unless you know.
So you just described jim norton's dream
girl.
Yeah.
This is a perfect.
Jim norton is.
I love him to death.
He's a perfect example to have someone
who's bulletproof because that's what he
is.
He's a,
he's charming at like,
like in his,
his fucking debauchery.
Uh,
he's,
he's a charming guy.
Girls love him and think he's adorable
at when he's saying some of the most
heinous shit onstage and on the air and
stuff.
You know,
where he's coming from.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
there's no mistaking it like he,
he wears everything honestly.
So,
uh,
he wrote the forward and in my book
permanently suspended.
He wrote,
he wrote the foreword.
He knows me,
like it's my brother first and then jim
norton.
Yeah,
like jim knows me really well.
We're,
we're really good friends and I love the
guy.
Why didn't you guys wind up doing a show
together when opie and anthony crashed?
I,
I think,
look,
I can't blame anybody because I think
that having the security of a steady
paycheck as opposed to the guy that just
got thrown off of everything,
opening,
starting his own thing,
uh,
it probably wasn't all that appealing to
jimmy who had just bought a new place in
the city and everything.
Is it just a,
it wasn't the right time.
And then,
you know,
as time went on,
he became the go to guy over at sirius,
um,
from the opiod anthony show.
So,
uh,
I would love to,
and I do is chip,
chip recent show and you know,
we're doing,
we're doing one in philly next week at
the live show.
Yeah.
We've been doing these live shows on
long island.
We did one up in boston and it's
hilarious jokes.
He comes out and the crowd goes fucking
wild and he's got to be in character the
whole time.
It's got to kill them.
It's got a killer.
And it's so much fun to do.
I love playing the straight guy cohost
to his fucking insane character.
But uh,
yeah,
we've done these live shows and they're,
they're really a lot of fun.
Um,
and he's just a fucking.
Oh my god,
it's so ridiculous.
He's gotta stay and look at those pants.
Yeah.
Places like packed and it's crazy.
You guys reading,
what are the notes?
Oh,
he,
he wanted us to.
He wrote,
he wrote like a,
uh,
almost a play,
but it's all just kissing chips ass and
how wonderful chip is.
And how thankful we are to be there.
Like it's so goddamn funny.
I love it.
He's a,
he's a brilliant man.
He's just A great guy.
And very fuckIng funny.
I knew from the first.
I think that also kind of.
I'm not blaming jimmy or anything,
but I think that helped to kind of break
up the o and a show in time.
I think opie started resenting the
little bit of that comradery that me and
jimmy were having.
Um,
me and jimmy kind of slowly started
pulling away and doing our own thing
like it was.
And the humor is,
you know,
the,
the more twisted the better.
I love sick humor.
He does too.
and we laugh.
We did a whole bit on,
on like lacy peterson and Scott Peterson
that the murder.
Yeah.
And you would think like,
obviously he murdered his pregnant wife
and dumped in the ocean.
What could possibly be funny about that?
Well,
people wrote trIbute songs with this guy
wrote a tribute song to her and it
another one of these self centered
assholes that thought he was going to go
viral by making a attributes.
And we started changing the words to the
song to make it just horrible involving
seaweed and things,
so it was terrible.
But me and jim are literally crying,
laughing,
and oh,
at least just kind of sitting there,
like not really able to jump in or not
kind of getting why we're laughing at
this sick shit.
Uh,
so it kind of pushed us further apart.
Um,
at that point.
Yeah.
We,
we both as people changed over the
course of the 20 years we worked
together 20 fucking years with anybody
do.
If this is nuts,
you got a girl that's suck your dick
every day for 20 years you're going to
be like,
oh fuck,
stop sucking my dick.
But now it's,
think it's open across from me,
you know?
Yeah.
Uh,
so you're going to get on each other's
nerves.
And I'm not innocent in the whole thing
either.
Uh,
but I was,
I'm a lot more laid back.
Like I,
I knew what real work was.
I worked for fucking living.
I did heating and air conditioning
installation and it was freezing cold in
the winter and boiling hot in the
summer.
And when I got that first gig and radio
because of opie and I'll always thank
him for that.
Uh,
I knew what it was like to work and I
didn't want to fuck that up.
So I plasTered a smile on my face at
every turn and did the show four hours a
day.
Everyone has someone at work that they
don't get along with.
You don't leave the old fucking,
you know,
you just deal with it.
And that's eight hours.
I had another 20 hours of the day that
didn't involve greg opi hughes so I
could deal with it.
Uh,
he was more like,
he had a express himself a little more,
which I guess is healthy in a way.
But uh,
I didn't need to,
so I didn't,
I didn't text him.
I didn't call him.
I uh,
he,
we got into an argument once and he
goes,
dude,
you never even been to my house.
And I go,
alright,
get everyone from the show in here.
Jim,
have I ever been to the house?
Nope.
Travis?
No.
Sam,
no.
Iraq.
No.
I've never been to anyone's house.
Let me tell you something right now.
Yeah,
that's something much chick would say.
I know that when my house toad,
it's exactly that.
Been in my house.
What does that mean?
What does that even mean?
I never been africa.
What the fuck are you saying?
I've never been to Spain.
What does that have to do with anything
that if,
if you had a problem with me not coming
to your house,
why didn't you ask me to come to your
house?
Yeah.
Like is there like a you asking me
everyday and I'm saying no.
Was saying no.
Right,
right.
What's going on?
It was always something like that.
And believe me,
I'm not gonna sit here and shit on the
guy.
I that my shows for that,
uh,
I'm not gonna fucking around.
I'm not going to sit on the guy.
But there were definitely personality
quirks and that I guess we both had.
But there was something like if,
if I,
I would party all the time and,
and you know,
I had to be there at 6:00
AM and I'm driving from roslyn long
island to New York city.
It's,
it's 25,
30 miles of just fucked traffic every
day.
He had to take you to get there.
It could be 35 minutes,
it could be an hour and a half based on
if someone's pulled over on the side of
the road,
some asshole crashes in queens,
whatever it was.
It was,
uh,
it was a shit drive every day and you
had to be there at six,
right?
Six o'clock the show started.
And so even at six they'd be that kind
of traffic.
Yeah.
It wasn't as bad as it got,
like seven or eight,
but you never really knew.
It could,
it could.
I was never late late,
but there were times I'd come in at
five,
after eight,
after six was pretty much as late as I
would,
I would be.
It was never more than that.
But he would go like,
he never had to say anything like the
music starts.
There's a little a bumper at the
beginning and by the time it starts,
I,
I'd sit down and he on mike would go,
um,
well,
I guess there was traffic anthony just
getting in and other bosses are
listening and it was,
it just wasn't necessary to do that,
you know,
it,
it kind of.
I was like,
you wanted something,
you got to be guys don't do that,
guys don't do that to each other.
You fucking sit down.
Don't say a word.
No one would know I'm late,
you know.
And that's what happened.
And it,
there were instances like that all the
time.
It's all in my book,
permanently suspended.
Uh,
there's that book out now.
It's out now.
A border's barnes and noble and we think
we have a copy of the green.
Oh yes.
Very good.
Uh,
but,
but I taught something.
Somebody's house.
It's in my house.
I talk a lot about obviously the
relationship and,
and uh,
with opie and,
and how it kind of slowly,
uh,
came apart at the seams,
I think toward the end.
Uh,
he just had had it.
He didn't want to do a show with me
anymore.
I don't think you want to do a show with
jimmy either.
That didn't last long and I knew it
wasn't going to last long and they,
I was the buffer between the two of
them.
That ended bad.
It really did.
Uh,
have you talked to jimmy about it?
Like he doesn't,
he doesn't express that kind of.
No,
no.
He doesn't like jimmy's a very loyalty
driven guy.
Uh,
like he takes that very seriously and if
he feels somebody fucking with him,
he really gets pissed.
Uh,
usually it can get talked out and
everything's cool after a little while.
Uh,
but this one,
uh,
this,
this work.
Yeah.
No,
no.
I think honestly,
the way you guys interacted with each
other,
what he was good for was sort of
directing the whole thing.
That's the impression that I got and I
mean,
how many times I do the show?
Dozens,
right?
Yeah.
I mean how many times it did it.
Absolutely.
But I always felt like what he did
really well was sort of guide things
like,
sit back more.
Let you guys be funny,
but,
but guide,
like,
figure out like maybe we need more of
this,
maybe we need more of that.
There was real value to that.
Absolutely.
But do you think that's fun when you go
out and do an appearance and everyone's
clamoring about a bit that me and jimmy
did or something for him.
Yeah.
And he's sitting there going like,
well,
I,
I pushed a button and I drove the ship
and I went to spots and if he knew it's,
it's,
it's funny because like,
yeah,
you're not going to be appreciated as
much,
but it's like a guy who,
uh,
is good at defense,
but he doesn't score a lot of points.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're not going to be lebron james.
It's necessary guys who score the points
though,
or the ones who everybody wants to talk
to you,
you know?
Yeah.
You ever see?
Uh,
I,
I Think of opiod,
like,
um,
you ever see the prestige,
the movie the prestige,
uh,
with the,
the two magicians know and it,
it,
it's,
it's a good movie.
It's a good movie,
but at one point,
uh,
because he has to use a body double,
the actual magician has to drop below
the stage and the body double comes out
and gets all the applause and he's under
the stage.
The real guy that did the whole act is
under the stage and he shuts his eyes
and puts his arms out,
like trying to enjoy the adulation from
the fans,
but it's not even him getting it.
And I think that kind of mindset was
there.
There's.
And then resentment starts bubbling up
and you start doing things like saying,
anthony just got in,
um,
you,
you hold things over people's heads.
the contract negotiations were a
nightmare every time.
And opiate always wanted a one year
deal.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Let's sign for 10 years.
Who gives a shit?
You know,
if they want to fire they're gonna fight
it anyway,
the contract or not,
but let's lock them in.
So if something happens,
at least we have a,
uh,
a settlement portion,
we can take half the,
what they owe us for five years,
whatever it is.
Not one year deal,
that's all I want because he always had
this delusion of grandeur,
like there was always something better
waiting for us to grab up and it's like
the truth of the matter was the glory
years of the o and a show were gone.
The new year's and the,
you know,
all that crazy fucking radio.
We were damaged goods after the sex in
st patrick's cathedral debacle.
We had a couple,
um,
we had a contest where people had to go
around New York city and have sex at,
at various famous locations with the
hard rock cafe and um,
empire state building,
things like that.
And we had spotters who were comics or
people that work for the show,
follow them around and they would call
us on the show and go,
all right,
we're here at the empire state building
and he's doing it.
I'm watching them right now.
So we had paul mecurio who was a comic
and he,
uh,
was following one couple of round and a
opiate put church on the list.
Um,
and I went like,
ooh,
I dunno man.
He goes,
it's just to read on the air and say
like what locations are,
and when we say church,
people go like,
oh,
dr ranges,
but no one's going to go to church.
Don't worry.
Well,
paul calls up and goes,
well,
we're here at st pat's and he's doing
the two point conversion.
you've got an extra two points if you
were fucking her in the ass at the
location because they all had point
values for how dangerous it was.
A pat was watching to be sure that it
went in the house.
Paul paul was watching.
Yeah.
the spotter was supposed to watch and to
watch this guy.
Fuck has grown the ass.
Yeah.
There was a lot of theater of the mind
going on to who knows what the fuck they
were doing or where I heard.
I hear it was in the vestibule outside
st pat's,
but regardless it's sex at st pat's and
a nope.
We looked at each other.
We both had digital delay,
like the delay button.
A seven second.
We have like a 32nd delay.
We both had buttons in front of us.
There was another guy in a locked room
down the hall that had a button to dump
out of because we were constantly doing
shit that would have gotten fcc
complaints.
So the boston stalled these buttons
everywhere while we both had our finger
on it.
Con like,
shit,
do we punch out of this?
It's hilarious guys.
Fucking his girl in the ass at st pat's
a and neither of us hit the button and
the guY down the hall didn't hit it.
We just went with it at that moment.
It's like,
that is one of those moments like talk
about a defining moment.
You move your finger one inch down and
that never happens.
It's amazing to think about.
What year was this?
A 2002,
I believe.
2,000.
It was,
yeah,
we,
it was nine slash 11.
Uh,
we,
we went through nine slash 11 on the air
and stuff.
And then I guess that summer maybe.
What year did you guys wind up on xm?
A 2004,
I think it was.
We had to sit out two fucking years out
of our contract.
Uh,
not working.
They didn't want us to go to mornings
because a clear channel radio,
which was another radio company and cbs
were,
we're kind of fighting for us,
a clear channel wanted us to do mornings
against howard stern who was on cbs.
Uh,
we worked for cbs at the time doing
afternoons,
so we,
we were put in a position where they
were both just throwing huge amounts of
money at us.
Uh,
and cbs was like,
we can't let them go to morning,
so we,
it would be impossible to beat howard,
but we would take enough listeners away
where he might not be number one
anymore.
That affects revenue,
you know,
you want to,
you want to sell the show as the number
one rated show.
Uh,
so cbs was doing anything they could to
keep us in afternoons with the same
company as howard.
Uh,
so it was the most lucrative contract we
ever signed.
It was a three year deal.
We signed it in I guess 2001.
And uh,
after one year they canceled the show
because of the sex at st pat's thing
that blew up.
I mean,
it was in the newspapers,
it was,
I had to look at opi and dopey on the
front page of.
I'm like,
fuck,
I'm dopey,
dopey.
I was so embarrassing.
My family and everything.
It was just fucking nuts.
So,
uh,
the cbs was like,
well,
we canceled your show,
but we're not letting you out of your
contract.
Like,
what does that mean?
We talked to our agent and he goes,
well,
you can't work.
They'Re not letting you work.
You'll still get paid and do it.
I'm talking of dollars.
This was millions of dollars that they
had to give us for two years.
But you think like,
oh,
that's awesome.
And back then there was no internet to
speak of.
Like,
like you had no way to contact your
fans.
Well,
you could have a website,
which is what are the ways that we
became friends as I wrote about you
guys,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
I wrote a big piece on my website about
how it was.
Yeah,
yeah.
A lot of people supported us,
but it got a.
In two years you'd just disappear on the
radio.
It's if you're not doing a show and
you're out there,
you will go away,
they will find something else.
So we were really worried about that.
And again,
damaged goods.
So no one was really clamoring to hire
us anyway,
but we went through two years where I
was just making huge amounts of money
and just find toys.
I would go.
I went to atlantis for a couple of weeks
ago in The Bahamas and I was literallY,
I was pulling my luggage to leave at
the,
uh,
the desk and I go to my chick,
I go,
what do we,
where are we going home?
He goes,
okay.
I said,
can I have the room for another two
weeks?
Like,
okay,
went back upstairs and just stayed for a
month.
I have no reason why am I going home
after two weeks,
you're so conditioned like how long a
vacation is and,
and that lasted for two years.
And then a satellite came calling,
which was we considered radio prison.
At that point it was radio jail.
Anybody that,
because everyone that had fucked up and
regular radio ended up in satellite,
like no one wanted to be in satellite
radio at the time.
They had no subscribers.
Me and opie sat on the side of,
uh,
the,
the belt parkway once by my house in
brooklyn.
And we were like,
let's see how many satellite radio
antennas we see because they used to be
very obvious shark fin,
big antennas,
aftermarket.
They stuck them and drilled them into
your roof.
It was terrible.
The installation process was stupid.
No one wanted to get fucked their car up
with this dumb antenna.
So we're looking at when like nothing.
And then,
oh look,
there's one.
And you know,
the money's one thing obviously,
but as a broadcaster you want to fucking
be talking to people you know,
you want,
you want to entertain people,
you want people to say,
wow,
that was good.
And there was just no subscribers back
then during our 10 years there.
It wound up getting very,
very good.
And,
and,
uh,
we had a lot of listeners,
but early on,
no one but satellite was calling.
And,
uh,
we,
we signed,
we signed the deal,
um,
but we,
we definitely would have preferred
terrestrial radio.
Yeah.
It's interesting now,
right?
Because now satellIte satellite became a
big thing when howard got on it
[inaudible] and people were talking
about it and then it became a big thing
because every new car you buy you'd get
a free 90 days or whatever.
But now no one gives a shit.
Yeah,
it's,
it's one of the short lived
technology's,
not that it's gone.
I think it'll always be there in some
capacity.
Man.
It is fucking clinging by a thread.
So many other,
um,
that's why they bought pandora.
I guess there's so many other streaming
outlets out there.
And the fact in podcasts,
the fact that podcasts are all free.
Yeah.
And then you can play them in a tunnel,
right?
It doesn't peter out on ya.
And uh,
you know,
you get that signal constantly now.
So it's,
it's not like the old days a,
every time you get in the car,
like your system identifies your phone
and then links up with commercials.
I remember when theY started playing
commercials,
like,
what the fuck is this?
I'm paying so that you can play
commercials.
He ouT of your fucking mind.
Yeah.
That was a.
It was supposed to be a commercial free.
They all talk about commercial free and
then it ends up.
Oh,
if you listen into seven days on seven,
I guess you want to have to listen to a
commercial.
But I think they have commercial.
Yeah.
They started throwing commercials on
everything.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Short lived,
uh,
technology.
It's weird.
And then to put all of your eggs in a
couple of baskets that are circling the
earth always seemed weird to me that you
can't get it in Hawaii.
I think I told you guys when I went,
I went to hawaiian vacation.
I got a car that had sirius xm built
into it.
It didn't work.
Yeah.
What the fuck is this?
You have to deal with a satellite
orbiting the,
you know,
something happens to the transmitter on
a terrestrial station.
They send an engineer up there.
He turns a few screws or what have you.
You know,
something fucks up in a satellite.
What are you going to do?
You know,
howard gonna get an a rocket and fix the
fucking dumb technology at this point.
Yeah.
totally.
Unnecessary,
unnecessary effect that sirius is still
transmitted from a thing in the sky down
to the ground.
Yeah.
And then it's transmitted from the
people on the ground up into the sky and
then back down to the people on the
ground.
Yeah.
That's what's going on.
It's just so unnecessary.
Just the people on the ground could just
send it to the people on the ground,
on the ground.
Why wouldn't you do breezy?
Yeah.
Especially in this day and age with the.
But they still doing it.
It's very weird.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
They're going to have to do soMething.
The model,
I don't know,
like I said by pandora,
maybe start scooping up a internet
companies,
but they're going to do.
I think they're going to move towards
that direction.
Yeah.
I think that's all.
You know what's really weird though,
it's like the Fucking am radio is still
a thing like,
like that's the weirdest thing to be.
The death knell for radio has been a,
it's been forever,
like the second another technology came
out.
IT was like,
well I guess that's it for radio and
television.
We have a,
an amazing invention.
yeah.
And radio was supposed to be dead but
it's just hangs in there.
People just can't let it go.
Regular radio,
especially a am
man.
I remember as a kid,
my dad having the agm or like music on
the am radio sounded like was coming out
of a tin can static and shit.
And that was kind of all you had.
I drove home a look like a year ago and
just on a goof I decided to uh,
put on am radio and I was listening to
an am radio show and I had a big smile
on my face all the way home because it
was like I was listening to the past.
Yeah.
it's like a time machine.
Right?
I was some weird.
One of the local talk shows a weird
local talk show in la where they were
talking about traffic and the dodgers
game and this and that.
It's archaic.
It's so strange.
Like first of all,
anything with anything that is trying to
inform you is just unnecessary at this
point.
Unless it's fake news,
the big cnn and fox news and everything.
Those will always be a fixture and
stuff,
but local fucking news.
Do you really need the,
the the team that cares at 6:00
and it's all just shit that you've
already seen online.
There's not one story that will be on
the 6:00
news that I don't already know in depth.
It's also the lowest rung of show
business in terms of competence.
People that they're terrible at it and
they're all drunks.
It's hilarious,
dude.
I have never seen a group of people that
can drink more than fucking newspeople.
They.
They just get hammered on instantly are
miserable.
I think that's it.
I think they're miserable.
Went through a whole thing when roseanne
was supposed to be on the podcast and
right after she got fired,
she announced she was going to come on
the podcast.
These fucking news casters started
showing up where our old studio is
actually.
They went to our old studio and they
were parked out front with cameras and
this is where I got.
I got upset.
I was like,
first of all,
you guys are terrible at this,
and second of all,
you just assume that because you're
there,
I have to talk to you [inaudible],
so because you see me,
I'm going to say something to you
because you put your camera and your
microphone face.
It doesn't work that way.
Fuck face.
I'm not going to talk to you.
You're not good at talking.
This is the reason why you do this job
like a really good job doing this
because you're not good at this.
You're not good at it.
You will one day get a really good job
doing this or you're just not good at
it.
Yeah.
One of those,
because right now you're right here and
I'm not talking to you.
This is nonsense,
like you're holding this fucking camera.
Hi.
We're here with cbs for news.
Fuck outta here.
I don't have to talk to you because you
have a camera in front of me.
Doesn't mind.
We're going to have an interview now.
Sometimes they feel like you're
obligated to address them.
Trying to come to my house.
Yeah.
I've had that happen.
It's not fun.
It's definitely not fun.
My neighbors,
I'm not talking to you.
They knocked on my neighbor's doors and
they want to know about me and stuff and
if you think like,
like we deal with la or New York,
imagine what the news team in fucking
east allah bum fuck like.
That's gotta be the worst.
They are just terrible at what they do.
Terrible local news in some podunk fuck
town is hilarious to watch.
It's one of the things that comics have
to do when they come into town to do
local tv shows.
Morning the morning chats out thing as
shitty as you think the vieW is the
talk.
As shitty as though shows morning
America fucking pens get together on
these shows in like the local one in
boise,
Idaho or dallas,
they're a thousand times worse,
worse,
just terrible death.
And,
and I,
I hate that there's such a double
standard when one of them fucks up,
when a newsperson fucks up,
they just apparently leave them alone.
Like where was everyone with a.
What's his name from,
from uh,
an.
Was it nbc?
Brian williams?
Well,
Brian Williams,
they kinda got on.
Uh,
but uh,
no.
Uh,
lauer.
Matt lauer.
Oh yeah.
Like matt lauer.
It was in the news or anything.
But where was,
where was the mike being shoved in matt
lauer's face as he's trying to fucking
go home or stuff that,
there was some of that.
I think he just hid.
I mean he went straight to long island
and went to the hamptons and he's never
left,
but where theY camping out in front of
his house like they did,
they were,
yeah,
they just,
he's just been banging divorces and
riding a motorcycle to trying to get
back on tv.
That is just stunning to me is how much
money he made.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Like I didn't know he was making that
much money.
Like that is insane.
And for Years for a long fucking like a
giant ranch in New Zealand,
it's like thousands of acres and you
decide you need that.
It's so crazy because he's got a,
some access issues like the people that
want to get to certain parts of the uh,
public land they have to go through his
ranch.
So there's like a,
an access issue like some sort of
easement where these people were
supposed to be able to drive through and
they're fighting it off and he should
just sit at his desk with that button
that opens the door.
But it lists a gate up so theY could get
through that button.
There's a misconception about that
button.
They all had that button.
Yeah,
that was.
it was because they had big offices and
they want to be able to lock their doors
suddenly interrupted on a phone call.
He wasn't,
so they could bang chicks in the office,
like women executives had that button
to.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
but that's the thing that sounded very
audrey,
audrey and d.
The media grabbed onto that and like,
oh my god,
he had a button,
the lock it.
You sit in there.
When I fuck around being our rep that I
want to fuck on,
I hit that button and just start fucking
some nervous girl.
Just seals that click goes,
oh fuck.
He hit the button.
There was a lot of that.
That was accentuated like there was a
one guest that brought in a bunch of sex
toys and he went back and he kept it in
his office and he was like,
oh,
he keeps a bag of sex toys in his
office.
Like this shit in this office.
I got a flame thrower.
Okay.
Elan gave me a flame thrower.
Yeah.
What am I going to do with it?
It's right there by the flame thrower in
his office.
Yes.
It's that kind of thing,
like if somebody gave me a bag of
dildos,
it will be right over there next to the
flame thrower.
He has a bag of cheetos.
I made a conscious decision to throw it
away,
or my wife found it.
It would wind up getting tossed,
but matt lauer decided to keep it in his
fucking closet.
Yeah.
Apparently he gave some people some.
I think the guy was getting laid.
Yeah.
That's what I think.
And I think a lot of what else happened.
The,
all the,
the details of it.
It seems to me that it's all of it is
like very blown out of proportion.
I don't like that,
uh,
that that's happening because everyone
is being lumped into the harvey
weinstein category,
which is the,
that's the tip of the pyramid right
there.
The tip,
right?
Right.
Cosby is literal one.
Yeah.
He's literally number one.
There was a woman who said this on,
I believe it was cnn or one of those
talk show.
She said,
he may very well be the biggest serial
rapist in history.
You even fucking build car.
Literally sitting back on my couch
going,
fuck,
bill cosby's the biggest serial rapist
industry.
Wow.
A time machine would be wonderful just
to see people's expressions when you
tell him like what's happening in the
whole,
a celebrity,
a forum,
like like why?
What's cosby's doing?
Have you seen a photo of howard cosell
standing next to bruce jenner and oj
simpson oj and it says,
I've seen the future and you're not
going to believe this fucking crazy.
Because we.
When we were kids,
we used to watch the cosby show when it
was,
when he was bill cosby,
the standup comedian that will go on hbo
and everybody loved him.
He was america's america's dad right
there.
The cosby show,
revolutionary on television.
He was at that time raping women at that
time.
It's insane.
Not just raping them,
but drugging.
Yeah.
And it in and friends,
daughters liKe he knew.
Come on over.
I'll help you with your career.
Wow.
Plump.
Yeah.
Dropped two in your fucking drink and
you feeling okay.
Put your feet up,
put your feet up,
and they'd be like,
okay,
I'll move it.
Good.
That's when I stick my dick in your
mouth.
In that hazy,
like a few of them just hazely regained
consciousness for a minute and just
remember seeing old bill pound in a way
with that fucking flounder.
I think he got the I later in life
apparently.
Yeah.
I think,
I'm not sure.
I thought they were using that as kind
of a sympathy thing,
but he looks pretty fucking blind him to
the same jail they sent whitey bulger.
Oh wow.
How about that bucket bags?
Full light and he's a.
He was,
what,
95 or something like that.
Why do you build culture?
Was he that?
I think it was that fucking all,
like in his nineties.
That's all.
That's a gRudge that someone held onto
for quite a while while the guy hated
rats apparently.
And that was the thing that whitey
bulger all throughout hiS time of
running the irish mob was ratting people
out the air.
That's what was really crazy.
He was another guy just like we were
tAlking about.
Um,
uh,
the fuck's his name.
The italian guy?
Yeah.
Gotti got no.
The other one.
Oh no.
He was in the mob.
Ratting out other people in the mob
while he was murdering people.
yeah.
Yeah.
Like the fbi allowed him to sell drugs
and do a lot.
He won the lottery twice while he was
doing this,
you know,
how that works and how the [inaudible]
would win the lottery and he would use
that as a way to show income.
So he would pay them for their lottery
ticket or steal it from him or whatever
they did it.
And then he would say,
look,
I won the lottery and then he would win
the lottery so that when he would have
all this money laundered,
it could avoid tax evasion charges.
That way I'll get proof of income.
Doesn't want to get that boat.
Where'd you get that cadillac?
Where'd you get that house?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
uh,
that's fucked up twice now.
Both live to win it twice.
He was,
uh,
yeah,
he,
he was,
uh,
the fbi was helping him too.
Obviously they were given up competitors
and uh,
well they,
they,
they were responsible probably for some
murders.
Yeah.
they would bring people to him like
that.
That was the thing like,
hey,
we're not going to kill anyone but we'll
bring this guy to you so you could have
a little chit chat and you know,
you're driving the guy to,
to his death.
Pretty much.
So he was living in an apartment in
santa monica with some girl,
just talked a lot.
And apparently she was yelling at him
and that's,
that's how he got arrested.
Like it,
like a domestic.
There was some screaming and yelling and
they were weird and that was what got
people looking at them like who the fuck
are these people?
And then they start.
I mean,
he wasn't even the like hide in Montana
or anything.
No,
no,
it wasn't even rigHt out there on a
ranch somewhere in the middle of nowhere
when no one's going to be suspicious.
He's in fucking santa monica in an
apartment that is fucked up.
Crazy.
I don't understand like,
how it's got to be the,
the most stressful life to lead.
Just on the run.
I watched that,
uh,
some of those shows like cold case files
and uh,
when they find these people,
you know,
the inmateS are saying about the brutal
prison hit on What he boulder chop chop
off the tongue.
His eyes out.
Oh my god.
That's like 89 or 89.
Jesus christ.
Yeah.
It's definitely got what he had coming
to them.
It shouldn't.
I don't see how anybody could argue that
apparently so no sympathy.
He says shit.
Just amazing.
And he's 89.
Made it to 89.
80 nine.
What was patrice like 40 when he died?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
How's that work?
I,
I have no idea.
But yeah,
I mean he,
he been
looking over shoulder constantly while
still in his wheelchair.
He was beaten to death with what inmate
call shank schlocks a lock in a sock
that is kind of a dr seuss weapon while
in his wheelchair before possibly having
his eyes pow partially gouged out with
shanks.
Oh fuck.
That's some real sandlands tried to chop
off his tongue.
Wow.
Sometimes it works.
Sometimes jailhouse justice actually
happens.
You don't,
you don't.
Uh,
you don't think it will.
But then it does sometimes,
sometimes,
sometimes people get what's coming to
them.
How do we get on the subject of why the
boundary?
I don't know.
We always,
we just ramble about this stuff.
They love it.
So I love that you've established your
own sort of media company.
I love that you decided to start your
own network,
but is it,
is it,
are there challenges like what we do is
pretty simple because we just put it out
there and then we put ads on it.
Right.
You know,
and,
or youtube puts ads on it.
But is it,
is it challenging to like,
I mean you,
you have a bunch of people.
Like when I was there,
other folks were coming in and they had
their shows in the studio as well and
they had you changed your green screen,
you know,
you should change the most convenient
way to kind of.
Instead of having a different set for
every show,
it's a green screen and then we just pop
it in a pop in the background.
We could do some pretty funny things
with it too.
We've done that.
I did a reading last week of a part of
my book and uh,
we went to an establishing shot of a
cabin and I moved to a chair behind the
green screen and it's just made by a
little fire burning and I.
Oh,
welcome.
I didn't,
I didn't expect you and you know,
so it's kind of fun to be creative with
the thing.
Um,
other than that,
yeah,
there are a lot of challenges.
It's a I,
I am not,
I am in front of the mic guy.
That's it.
I don't really like any of the other
parts of the business.
This,
it,
it's weird because this is the ceo of
the business or I'm the guy.
Keith though is the guy.
I've delegated a lot of the
responsibility as to the tech end of
everything and uh,
finding the people we need to run
equipment and stuff over the course of
the years and it's worked out very well.
Um,
but,
but it is one of those things.
It's,
it's two companies.
You have the entertainment that's going
into the microphone and then all the
shit you need to get that to the people.
And the business model and,
and you know,
billing and all that shit that I can't
fucking be bothered.
I have video games to play.
I can't be bothered with that shit.
So you operate on,
it's a subscription.
People pay by the month and you get a
ton of shows.
They get the Mike Ward show.
Yeah.
Uh,
Mike Ward,
who was in here last week.
Yeah.
And they get a aaron and gino doing in
hot waters,
our morning show and they are just out
of fucking control.
They're the one show that I watched
sometimes they go like,
oh really?
Wow.
That's,
I wouldn't do that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They're brutal comics.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
The comics in uh,
in New York and then they tour around.
I'm really funny guys.
Then,
um,
so this is the,
this is the page with all show on it.
Yeah.
I,
I pilfered a bill schultz and joanne
know socinski from fox news.
They used to be on fox news,
a red eye and stuff.
East side.
Dave is a,
an insane motherfucker from the old ron
and fez show what's in hot water.
And hot water is the morning show.
That's a.
Yeah,
that's aaron and gino.
Kevin brennan,
who is just a mental patient.
Uh,
kevin's scares me.
He yells a lot.
I,
I come into the studio and I just hear
his voice booming,
yelling and I get an anxiety attack.
Like it's my dad yelling at mom back in,
in the,
in the old days a.
Yeah.
It was just a,
uh,
you know,
we,
we were always looking for a many shows
you have on shows that fit.
I don't know how many that is available
to stream.
Like anytime you want.
Yeah,
yeah.
Every show.
Most of the shows go out live.
I like the element of just a little
danger there of,
of being live as it goes out.
I like that.
I don't know what it is,
but just knowing you could edit
something might make you a little lazy
as you're doing it.
You can't stop.
You have to keep calling.
Jamie brought it up like it feels
different and we've done shows that
aren't live.
Yeah.
Yeah it does.
If something happened with streaming at
one point in time,
we fucked up and we couldn't stream,
so we just edited it and put it or a
filmed in advance rather than put it up
later.
But it was like,
is this field feels weird?
It does.
It's because there's a net.
There's a net down there.
You could,
you could leave.
If you had to take a piss,
you could go,
hey,
I gotta take a piss.
I go,
you know,
this is,
you're going out like,
this is it.
Hi.
Hey,
here it is a.
I like,
I like that.
Yeah.
That's something that there's a feeling
that there's people listening right now,
right?
Yeah.
And everything's archived.
So a subscribers can get a all the past
shows from all the channels available.
Can they download audio as well as
video?
Yeah,
yeah.
Audio only,
um,
uh,
audio and video.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
we give a lot of options.
Uh,
we went with subscriber based because
when I got the boot from a serious years
ago,
uh,
I couldn't imagine people want me to be
hawking their products in the first
place.
Uh,
and,
and I didn't want to be beholden to
sponsors,
I can't have anyone telling me what I
can and can't say anymore,
just ain't going to happen.
But is there an issue trying to get
people like,
uh,
I had a friend who was on radio and they
left and went to do a podcast nana
subscription podcast.
Yeah.
And he,
what he was saying is,
it's really difficult to grow.
Look,
you have to keep those people that you
have to keep them happy and he,
they would do things to engage with them
and they would do like little events
where they'd go to a bar,
meet everybody and do a show from there.
He said,
but it's really hard to grow because
people don't want to pay when there's
all these different shows they could
just get for free.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's always a challenge.
But there's also the commodity that
people can't get anywhere else is
entertaining.
Shows like you could have a free show
that sucks and there's plenty of those
out there.
Uh,
but if you're good at what you do and
you already have an audience,
because I say it all the time,
corola had the greatest line once he was
being interviewed in so and said,
uh,
how do you,
how do you make a successful podcast?
He goes,
oh,
okay.
Rule number one,
be famous.
And I was like,
yeah,
you gotta.
So I figured if we get up and running in
a month,
and then keith,
uh,
figured it out that we could hold onto a
lot of the o and a audience that would
come over and subscribe.
Get it quick,
get up.
Yeah.
And that's why.
Thank god I had that studio already
built in my basement.
Yeah.
I was able to.
All we needed was the logistics of,
of pumping it out onto the internet in a
bigger number than I was doing at three
in the morning.
Were doing some of them outside too.
Yeah,
yeah.
We'd set up the camera out by the pool.
Like my first guest was dice,
which was hilarious.
Yeah.
Dice came by,
we sat by the pool and then later on he
went downstairs in my basement,
I that karaoke stage and he was singing
elvis karaoke songs.
It was hilarious.
And that's one of those voluntary like
dice is in my basement singing.
Elvis did that fucking awesome.
Uh,
but yeah,
so,
so that model works for us and it's been
working,
but I'm kind of seeing a,
you gotta keep on your toes in
especially a technology based business.
We were just talking about satellite
radio,
like you don't,
you just can't tell what's going to
happen.
You really gotta kind of look for future
trends and whatnot.
And uh,
maybe more of a hybrid thing because
it's a balancing act of bringing new
people in and like you said,
keeping the people that are there
already,
but bringing new people in with some
free content.
So maybe get tiered subscription thing
where there is a free level with
sponsors.
Uh,
but then a tiered,
a premium level with the material that
we've already had.
Maybe a past shows or something or extra
content.
But,
so we're,
we're always trying to think of what
might be a good option.
When I first fired this thing up,
we had no fucking clue.
I mean this was usually,
you would kind of do some kind of a
research testing or whatever,
marketing analysis of day parts and shit
like that.
And I just was like,
I could,
I could be here by 4:00
PM.
How long is this show going to be?
Six.
Two hours.
Four to six.
I could,
I could go out at six and then I don't
have to be there until 4:00
PM.
It's fucking easy.
Still lets me party a monday through
friday.
Fuck that.
I want the three day weekend all the
time for the rest of my life.
So that's what we do monday through
thursday.
And then we have programming on friday
in the slot that I'm supposed to begin,
uh,
during the week.
So it just,
I wanted,
I didn't want to fucking be driving
myself like that forever.
So cut back on the hours,
the days and it worked.
So,
you know,
I'm very happy with that.
But again,
you know,
we're always assessing and seeing what
we could do to kind of build it because
it is that trade off of audience,
like obviously we're not going to get as
many people watching on a subscriber
based than we would if it was free with
spots,
but,
you know,
do you want to cut down on the paid
subscribers and boost it up and then how
far do I,
I go with advertisers where somebody can
call them and fuck me over now and do I
truly have free speech now or just free
as I can be a what?
A subscriber base.
So,
uh,
it's a balancing act.
I see what you're saying.
Look,
you don't want to totally abandoned the
subscriber model because then you're at
the mercy of subscribe,
have a advert of advertisers and it gets
like we have advertisers now we have a
couple of them,
uh,
that we pop maybe two spots on a show
and I do.
They're all live reads.
So I,
I make them fun and funny and people
like,
I learned that from howard years ago
when howard,
we'd go to spots before he was
syndicated to when he had all the time
in the world,
sometimes you didn't even know he was
still in a commercial break.
It was just funny.
So I try to keep it light and fun and
add in things.
Uh,
so it doesn't feel so intrusive,
but I don't live in thai by sponsors.
It's not,
it's kind of supplements the subscribers
stuff.
So,
uh,
that works.
And I don't know,
maybe I'm paranoid because of my past
that,
uh,
that sponsors might get pissed at what
I'm saying.
But when I look at the shows,
especially the shows I've been doing in
the past year or so,
they're not as harsh as they were.
I was really fucking angry.
Uh,
like five years ago when I started this
whole thing.
I can't believe it's almost five years
already,
uh,
that I've been doing this a compound
media.
And uh,
I was just pissed and the show was a
platform of like venting and,
and revenge.
And like,
I just,
I wanted to fucking yell and be pissed
about things and bang the desk about
politics and society and,
and uh,
it,
it came off as very angry.
Uh,
and then as,
as time went on,
I realized like people would tell him he
got dude just be funny,
like just joke about shit and you don't
have to be serious.
Like I thought for some reason I had to
do almost like a political show,
um,
because of the fact that you had gone
through so much shit.
Yeah,
I was resentful.
I was pissed.
And,
and you know,
it's a,
it's one of those things that really
carried over onto the show,
but the past couple of years,
I guess it's been,
especially with bringing artie lange on
board for the eight months he was with
me,
uh,
it's very difficult to get into any kind
of a commentary on society with hardy
lank sitting there.
It was odd.
It was great.
I mean,
you know,
the,
the preface,
everyone gives us fucking love already.
He's hilariously funny.
Uh,
so quick and just a goofy knock around
regular guy a,
but the demon span,
the demons.
It was,
it was kind of rough to deal with.
Like I said,
I'm a relaxed guy if already didn't show
up one day I do the show myself.
Didn't need,
do the show with opi for awhile.
No,
he was a guest on the show and,
and I guess be approached him to be a
cohost or something to eat.
He said no.
Um,
but yeah,
it was never part of the show.
I thought he was going to be part of the
show.
Yeah,
there was kind of a rumor going around
for awhile.
Uh,
so when he came on I was like,
it's not going to kill me if he doesn't
show up for a day every so often because
I'll just do the show myself.
Uh,
but it turned out to be a little more
than that.
And there was some days that were really
good and other days where it was a
little frayed around the edges and uh,
you know,
redundant.
He's got different kinds of demons.
Boza bub,
he's got like the main demon.
He really does,
man,
and it's so fucking sad to say because,
I mean,
there's no question about the talent.
There he is.
He's hilarious and a great guy.
Great guy.
You'll always hear that.
You always hear that.
I,
I remember when we hired them,
it was a,
I was at the comedy cellar and dave
attell,
can you let go?
So you're working with rd.
I'm like,
yeah.
He goes,
well,
welcome to the wonderful world of the
3:00
AM phone calls and not being able to
find him like,
oh fuck,
what did we get ourselves into?
And,
and that's kinda what we've got
ourselves into.
But again,
I mean,
I had a great time.
His,
he's one of the funniest motherfuckers,
especially on a mic like that.
Who would think that when jackie marlin
left the stern show,
they'd be able to replace them with
somebody that was just funny as fuck.
Have legendary shows with,
with a rod on.
And um,
you know,
he,
he definitely earned a place in,
in broadcast history,
but we just,
you know,
after eight months it got a little too
crazy to unpredictable and you need some
predictability.
What was,
what was bad about it?
Well,
it was the attendance issue was a little
odd.
I'm like a principal.
Yeah,
yeah.
The attendance.
He wasn't,
he was tardy.
Uh,
and,
and there were some days he was fucking,
just,
most days it was awesome,
but there were some days where,
you know,
the heads down,
it was kind of kind of a little iffy and
you know,
regardless,
I know he knows that too.
I mean he's,
he's,
he lives in that body,
so,
you know,
he knows it.
So it was a little odd.
Um,
and then we picked up dave landau,
who's a young comic out of detroit.
He filled in a couple of times when we
had them as guests on the show.
And then he filled in a couple of times
during a few sabbaticals that he was
away for a week or so.
And me and dave just hit it off.
He's got a great sense of humor.
He's a little twisted.
He's got a great backstory.
The guy was just a fucking piece of shit
for a long time.
His stories about like,
drunk driving crashed.
Every car he had,
he was arrested 15 times before he was
18,
like just a disaster.
And you look at him now.
He's got a great wife,
a beautiful kid.
He's a working comic and he's awesome.
He did.
He knows how to cohost my show.
He,
he gets it.
uh,
we don't step on each other.
He knows exactly what to throw in and
when,
so a really happy with the,
with the tape.
Landau.
He only did one show with them the last
time I was in town with.
Yeah,
he's great.
He's a good guy,
man.
Dude.
Yes.
Smart and really decent.
Like it's so weird to see people that
you didn't know when they were such fuck
ups and fucked up because like,
you know,
you almost want to go.
All right,
come on,
we'll just drink one night.
I want to see what a disaster you are,
you know,
uh,
because,
you know,
you just don't know how fucked up people
can get a,
but you'd never know.
He's,
he's a,
he's a decent guy.
I like what you're doing,
man.
I love it.
I love that.
Cool.
You're doing something different in you,
you basically,
you got put into a corner and said,
all right,
I'm going to figure my way out of this.
It was a lifeboat at first,
but it was really expanded it now and
it's,
it's become a really interesting thing.
Yeah.
And,
and I never expected it.
I gave it a lot of thought in between
being fired and when we finally fired it
up a compound media,
I was like,
what do I do too?
Why do I go fucking buy a ranch
somewhere in the middle of the sticks
and get guns and write a manifesto or
something or,
you know,
I didn't know what to do.
Uh,
no one was knocking on my door to
fucking get me a job.
So,
uh,
when,
when the idea came to do this,
it was pretty much all right,
I want to do this.
And regardless of how many subs I guy
get,
the overhead is going to be barely
anything.
It's me and my basement doing a
broadcast.
So,
uh,
I wasn't really worried about the number
of subscribers or anything like that.
And when we launched and it was really
successful,
uh,
during the course of that year,
we started getting other shows,
legion of skanks,
uh,
the guys out there.
I'm big jay oakerson and uh,
steve smith and uh,
no,
they have their own thing.
Louis j gomez.
Yeah.
They got their own thing,
um,
on,
on their own network.
Uh,
but for a while they were doing their
show from my house,
which was so weird.
It was like,
because you need their legion of skanks
with them.
They have their,
part of their show is that live
audience.
So I'd have people coming into my
backyard that I didn't know from a hole
in the wall that had driven out to
roslyn long island to sit on folding
chairs in front of the guys.
And I'm walking around my basement,
like,
who are these?
Like,
this is a little weird.
It's a little intrusive,
but it's cool.
But it.
And then it really started getting
fucked up because during the summer
months,
uh,
they all jumped in the pool.
So now they're swimming in my pool.
Legion of skanks was in my pool and it
was the weirdest,
it was cold and we'd all just,
you know,
have a few beers talk,
you get to know people.
So it wasn't that bad.
No one ever did anything bad.
They respected the house and everything,
which was very cool.
Um,
and then gavin was doing the show.
We got gavin on board from my house and
a lot of times it was at night,
so I'd be upstairs on my couch watching
tv or something.
He'd finish up,
come upstairs and sit on the couch and
be like,
hey man,
what's that?
And I'm just like,
I just don't want to talk.
I talked all day,
I'm just,
I want to watch tv.
So it became a little weird and after a
year,
uh,
keith was like,
let's get a place in the city.
It's easier for guests.
So we've got a place at a 35th and
seventh right near penn station,
which works great.
You know,
I take the train and now I don't have to
fucking drive into the city a,
although that's another nightmare,
the transit long island railroad.
But,
uh,
it,
it just works out better that way.
It gets me out of the house.
It's a separation of personal life and,
and,
uh,
the,
the job.
So it works out.
I liked my podcasts in my house too.
I think everybody does a little kids to
hear him in the background screaming at
each other.
Mommy,
she took my thing,
you know,
because they were really little at the
time because doing it for nine years,
the holy fuck.
Yeah.
Oh my god,
no time.
Yeah.
So I did it in my house and then we
started doing some of them,
the ice house and then I got a,
got a place,
got a,
uh,
the last one.
Yeah.
Yes.
You went to remember that.
And then as the show got bigger,
I just said,
let's get a big place.
Let's.
This is insane joe.
I like,
I don't know how much you've shown the
people on your show.
Do you venture out and show him
anything?
Because it's,
it's insane.
It's a fucking airplane hangar.
This is giant and everything in every
corner is cool.
Like it's all just cool.
There's for a,
you got weights and mats and then that,
that hunting thing,
that archery game.
A game.
No hunt.
It's amazing.
It's,
you know,
it is a game.
The scores like you compete against each
other.
Yeah.
You're firing real arrows with your
compound.
Bow into what does that kevlar kevlar
screen.
The,
the tips are flat like the top of a
water bottle.
So slaps it.
It doesn't penetrate.
Yeah.
I went to a gun range a couple of times
on long island that also used a video on
a screen that was made with a giant
rolls of paper,
one horizontal,
one vertical and a,
a sensor would read the light that would
come through when a bullet hit and uh,
that would record where you shot and
accurately show that.
And then after too many holes got in,
all you have to do is wind the paper a
little bit on each one and it,
it misaligns the holes.
So now you got a whole new sheet of
paper to shoot at.
Oh wow.
Uh,
yeah.
And,
and it was,
it was very cold to be able to shoot it.
Video targets of,
you know,
the bad guy.
Well,
it sounds like really good for real life
situations for hunting.
That thing's amazing.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you're not just looking at a bullseye,
like a typical target face.
You're looking at the crease behind the
shoulder where you're trying to hit the
heart.
By the way,
you nailed that one.
I like the second one.
You did.
It was a deer.
Just a video of a deer standing there
and it's moving.
It's not a still picture.
And you drew that back and hit it
exactly in the crease behind the leg.
That was a hard shot.
Really cool.
This fucking game is very addictive
though.
You'll be out there pulling that boback
you fuck your shoulder up,
pulling back 70 pounds all day long.
Gets super addictive.
Like think about how addictive it is to
play video games.
Oh yeah.
Think about competing against another
bow hunter and you talking shit to each
other.
Playing this game with deer walking out
in the field.
It's really great practice for actual
bowhunting.
Yeah.
You could tell it's very accurate to
wherever that,
uh,
wherever the bolt hit,
it's fucking right.
Right on the money.
Very,
very cool though.
This place is awesome.
An amazing.
I can't even you,
you were,
you know,
you took the ball and fucking ran with
it,
man.
You really did.
This is amazing.
Just an amazing accomplishment.
Like you're not your,
the guy like,
like people are like,
oh,
you're gone on rogan's podcast.
Oh shit.
He's the guy at you.
You're like ended up being the guy
because of you guys.
That's great.
Awesome man.
Because of being a guest on o and a and
then watch crazy compound.
That's absolutely where it all started.
Crazy.
I just want it.
When I was doing that I,
I,
it was trial and error.
I would go to b and h photo in manhattan
and just buy shit and take it home,
hook it up and go,
ah,
that don't quite work.
Throw something in the closet,
get something else.
And slowly built up what I needed to
have at work.
My goal was really to have lower thirds
and video over my shoulder and look into
the camera with a teleprompter so it
looked like the news,
but it was done by a drunk guy who is
good to go off and just sing karaoke.
Horrible language.
Like that to me was always funny,
like it was a parody of a real tv show.
I want it to look good.
Not just a grainy camera with xbox
headset.
Just talking about this at the comedy
store.
The other night we were watching the
news,
it was on the television and we're
saying how much better would the news
being if you get a couple of us and get
fucked up and start smoking weed and
they just.
But the real news,
like actual real stores like oh
shit,
look what the fuck that guy just did.
And then of the news is just with comics
like I've,
I've,
I've actually af after doing that at the
comedy store and watching them and
talking to a couple of friends have
actually thought about doing that.
Like having a nightly news show or a
morning news show or just a show where
one hour of the day is just like,
you get the ap feed,
the news feed and you've got video to go
with it and you do a stoned out or drunk
new show.
Yeah,
we,
we have a guy michael malice that does
kind of a daily wrap up show at 11:00
PM and it's hilarious because he'll put
like the other day was talking about
tucker carlson and the graphic comes up
and it says a tucker calls it,
but it's a picture of um,
who the fuck was it a sean hannity?
It was a picture of sean hannity and he
does shit like that all the time.
And people like,
dude,
that's not tuck his wife.
No,
I thought it was,
but he does that on purpose.
Like he fucks with the graphics and the
ticker at the bottom and everything.
And it's really weird.
It's really funny.
He's a,
he's a smart guy too.
He's a clever,
a little shit.
Uh,
yeah.
So,
but that's shit like,
that is great.
We did it.
We did an election show during the
presidential election a couple of years
ago.
Then gavin was on that one and we had
all the big american flag waving in the
background on the green screen and
everything,
and,
and we were calling it like a sporting
event.
Depalo was there,
uh,
and it really turned into like a
football game.
You're just going,
oh my god,
we just got Florida.
Oh my god.
It was so.
And it was.
We were all drinking and lab and it was
an election coverage like the news would
do,
but we were just hammered and laughing
our balls off.
Know what do you think happens to gavin
now?
A well,
no one bounces back from this.
That kind of shit.
It's so tough.
It's a different kind of shit that he's
in right now.
Cult leader,
like he's in this,
they've,
they've got david koresh as mouse has.
He's got the eye of sauron on him.
Just once that's on you.
It's very hard to shake that fucking
thing off of you.
Yeah,
if anyone can do it.
It's gavin.
He's been really reborn a couple of
times.
He was supposed to be trans thing.
Not really.
Ah,
they gave him a lot of shit for that and
he got plus this company.
Yeah.
But that's like professional stuff
that's not like show biz stuff now he's
in this weird show.
Biz exile.
A
place.
Yeah.
Willie's on crtv.
That's still real.
He does a show there.
Yeah.
Fuck watches that.
I don't know.
You know,
I,
I see clips of him.
But um,
yeah,
it's raised that.
What is crtv?
It's another kind of an internet thing.
Yeah.
But more straight news kind of based a
why would they have him on it?
Uh,
he was on there.
He got hired by them maybe a year or so
ago,
but if they're trying to do something
straight,
he's not like you at least kind of the
goofy.
I think the goofy.
Yeah.
Aspect of it.
And then they'll have,
you know,
the regular straight laced guy.
Why don't you have them on compound
anymore?
Uh,
he got a better offer to go over there,
you know,
and I can hold anybody back here.
Why you don't chew.
It is weird though,
because you can be stricken from the
record as they showed with Alex Jones.
They just,
holy fuck.
Did they just get rid of him?
He is a nonperson.
They fucking took every aspect of his
uh,
feed off of every bit of social media
and it's obviously a coordinated effort.
Yeah.
This is not just one company that also
competes with another company that all
of a sudden they all just universally
decided on their own independently.
Yeah.
No,
they,
they coordinated that I can't stand the
uh,
you know,
I am an absolutist with free speech.
I and,
and I know the fucking line.
It's a private company can do what they
want.
Freedom of speech is about the
government in this.
It's like,
yeah,
but are you okay with that?
Are you okay with a faceless
corporation?
Uh,
deciding what you can watch and see and
hear and who can speak based on nothing
but this arbitrary ideology that comes
out of a building.
Like,
I don't like that.
I want anyone to have the ability to
speak about anything they want,
no matter how repugnant it is.
Like like meet it with a lively debate.
Well,
here's the.
Here's a perfect example.
Forget Alex Jones was talking about what
we talked about earlier.
Laura loomer versus louis farrakhan.
You where's your consistency?
You've got to explain to me how that
works.
How does that was,
is it okay for the guy on twitter to be
calling jewish people?
Termites?
I mean that.
That is.
That's something you exterminate.
Yeah.
Yes.
It's nazi Germany type.
Yeah,
exactly.
How is that?
Okay.
That's okay with you,
but then,
I mean,
how about look,
it works that way on the left as well.
Like how about that guy that just got
kicked off of cnn as he was talking
about the jewish people,
Israel,
palestine and that he's for palestinian
liberation and they were like,
fuck you,
you're done like this.
This decision that or the thought
processes involved in decisions that
they make is not based on rational
thinking and objective reasoning.
It's so arbitrary.
You just don't know.
It's based on which way the culture
swinging and the culture is swinging in
a way that avoids any,
any possible accusations of racism.
If you think in any way,
shape or form,
you're going to be thought of as racist.
You avoid that because there's some
people that say horrific shit about
white people.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They don't get van literally calling for
their death and,
and yeah,
they don't.
The,
that got hired by New York times and it
was a massive uproar because she had so
many anti white things on her twitter.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The uh,
the asian girl.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
just all that ridiculous
leftwing woke nonsense.
You're allowed to be completely racist
against white people.
Massive generalizations against white
men in particular.
Like,
yeah,
it is.
It absolutely is discrimination.
And it's absolutely what you're doing is
you're being prejudiced,
but you're being prejudice with a stamp.
You've got a stamp of approval.
Yeah.
You're allowed to be.
And I love the,
the rules that are made up that are
ridiculous.
It's like,
oh,
you're a racist.
I can't be a racist.
I'm this or that or that.
I can't be sexist.
I can't be this.
Like who's making these fucking rules
up?
Exactly.
How come I am not privy to any of them?
Of course I can.
I can call on any of these.
Did.
The beautiful thing about that is that
hypocrisy will eventually bite them in
their ass and people who are rational,
who listened to the argument against it,
and so will you absolutely can be sexist
against men.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Ken,
of course,
and you are a lot of feminists are 100
percent sexist against men.
There's this feminist that I follow her
fucking twitter picture,
the image,
the big one.
The banner one says,
trust.
No man.
Okay,
well good.
Fucking luck.
Good luck cutting out half the
population.
Don't trust them.
How about trust?
All women?
You're going to do that.
Well,
great.
Congratulations.
Because you got about 15 to 20 percent
and that's.
You're going to have to trust all of
them.
Yeah.
Good luck.
You got 80,
80,
85,
90 percent maybe.
Good gals got polluted.
Polluted population.
Just like men.
Population of men is a polluted
population of women.
If you,
if you thought that you were going to
get pure drinking water without dropping
in those,
uh,
purification tablets,
you're going to get some shit in there.
Yeah,
you're going to get,
you're going to get sick.
The,
yeah,
that there's no,
there's no 100 percent on any of that.
So when we saw the whole believe all
women thing that happened during the
cabinet hearings,
I didn't do that bit the other night.
I did a now tell it to you off air.
I'll tell you something off here.
That's
it.
It's,
it's,
it's crazy.
Like the idea that anyone would say,
believe all women is as mentally saying,
believed no women.
Exactly.
It's the same stupid thing because
there's going to be assholes is going to
be pieces of shit.
Um,
I was saying on the show the other day,
like no one really wants equality.
No one.
Equality isn't good.
The,
the fight for equality is where it's at
and you never want to attain it because
then you're not special anymore.
If you're fighting for equality that
you're always a victim.
There's always a,
an oppressor and you're fighting that
once you're equal,
you can be called a shithead.
You could be called stupid everything
else.
You're just another face in the crowd
with another stupid voice that probably
shouldn't be heard.
Uh,
so no one ever really wants equality.
No matter how much they're clamoring was
get achieved.
You're going to find some reason why
it's not right.
Why it's not valid.
And you can still say that you're
being victimized by something that
currency in it.
Yeah.
There is.
There's,
there's definitely equity and being a
victim and not being equal yet,
but you're fighting.
You can say things that other people can
say.
We see it all ties.
You can be completely prejudice.
You can do a lot of things.
You could never do if you were another
race.
Yeah.
And now you see this,
uh,
that avi naughty guy,
that lawyer just hilarious.
He had the whole believe all women and
then like a fucking movie script spins
around and bites him right in the ass
where he's like,
I didn't do that.
She's lying.
It's like the fact that it happened so
fast.
Like if that would have been hilarious
if it happened two years from now,
but the fact that it happened right
after that is just beyond hilarious.
Like the asia argento chick,
right?
Yeah.
The other one,
the one who was accusing harvey
weinstein of raping her.
Right.
And then turned out that she had been.
It's basically what,
what do they call it?
Statutory rape when you have sex with 17
year old boy,
which.
Yeah,
I don't think it is.
I don't think you think it is either,
but the law's the law and the fact that
it came out,
it came out that bordain had paid this
kid off there the whole time.
They're all just believe all women and
like who don't believe that one.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
That one we probably shouldn't believe.
I mean this is,
this is a problem.
You got a real fucking problem.
And the fact that all that went down,
you know,
I mean it's just when these things play
out like this,
it almost makes you wonder like,
god,
I don't,
I don't really believe we're living in a
simulation.
But if we were living in something
that's designed to almost,
it instills this lack of appreciation
for reality,
it seems.
It all seems so bizarre and ludicrous
and it keeps people keep like when,
when the anthony wiener got in trouble
for pulling his dick out,
I swear to god there was part of me that
was going.
This doesn't even make sense.
Like this is so,
so obvious.
It's so like right there.
Yeah.
So on the button.
Not even subtle enough.
A lot of that stuff.
It seems like everything works out too
much.
Like it's scripted.
Like during,
during trump's campaign,
I kept saying he's got a.
When I go,
this doesn't play.
If he doesn't win,
this isn't rocky one.
This has to be rocky too.
He's got a fucking win.
It's not about the battle and the
bravery and that he's got to win this
for this to work.
To really highlight the theater of the
absurd.
Right?
He's got to win.
Yes.
This is all fucking one spotlights in
the air.
I see the theater of the absurd.
I mean that guy being president with his
fake hair sprayed down and orange skin
with the wider on the eyes.
It all seems so fake.
Everything he says,
he says the way he looks like.
Yeah,
everything is insane.
I still,
every time I see him walking down the
stairs at air force one,
I'm just like,
holy fuck.
Donald trump is the president.
Like what?
What kind of wacky world of really wacky
world,
ideally wacky.
The other day when he was given that
speech about elvis and it's just like
people telling me,
I looked like elvis.
That's what people have told me.
If I wasn't blonde,
I looked like elvis and and it's like
no,
no one told you that a little bit like
elvis.
No one ever told you that.
Maybe your belly right when elvis was
sitting on the ball for the last time,
but that's about it.
How about when that reporter confronted
him with the two of them together?
Well,
when I look at that picture,
if he was to me,
a leg leg,
the king maybe.
Oh my god.
A little bit about the upper right hand
corner one.
Have you.
Have you ever seen anyone do that?
Fat was my favorite.
Fat elvis.
Too much baby.
Of course.
A thousand times now.
Have you ever seen someone so committed
to a comb over for so many years?
Like so committed.
It's not just a coma.
I don't know what it is.
It's a contraption walking up the stairs
of air force one where the wind's
blowing wind behind.
You see the whole back of his head is
bald.
Like where's the hair coming from?
It was like a fucking vader's head
without the helmet is kind of looked
like that weird.
Like what's going on?
You never know where it's starting and
where it ends at,
how long it is.
It's like,
look at that.
Oh my god.
That's just a picture.
The video is more disturbing because you
see the flops.
Yeah.
Chaos.
Well,
how about,
you know,
he didn't want to go out there for the
4th of July memorial because he didn't
want to get his hair with his hair wet
in the rain.
That was a.
Yeah,
that's what they were saying.
I don't know that it's such a weird
thing.
Like he was September 11th.
That's what it was.
The president of nine slash 11 was a
veteran's memorial or veteran's day.
Isn't it odd that the president is a guy
that's so like insecure than ever for
decades.
He has to fucking do a,
a fucking dairy queen ice cream.
Fucking move on his head every day.
So he's fat.
Like if your.
The thing is like if you really
concerned so much about your looks or
why are you fat while you're at it?
I don't think he thinks he's fat.
I think it's like one of those guys that
you talked about having a body
dysmorphia body dysmorphia.
They just,
he looks in the mirror and sees elvis,
like young leather clad elvis.
Yeah.
He's got this weird thing.
You know,
where he doesn't believe in exercise
because he feels like the body is like a
battery and if you put any energy and
where is it out?
Well,
the motherfucker is up at all hours.
The,
uh,
during the campaign for the midterms,
he was doing three rallies a day flying
all over the country and he never seemed
to be like he was falling asleep or
losing energy.
So I don't know what he's doing.
Well,
you know about all that he says I get
exercise.
I mean,
I walk,
I this,
I that trump's nobody wants that.
During the oval office.
I run over to a building next door.
I get more exercise than people think.
I run over to a field basing my exercise
is incredible.
He's on allegedly,
according to one reporter,
he's on diet pills and that he's been on
diet pills forever.
And then there's a prescription that,
I mean,
he,
he actually even cited the exact dwayne
reed pharmacy where he was supposed to
take this for a little while and he
wound up taking it for years.
I was taking some form of amphetamines,
which in this day and age,
if you would be fucking stunned if you
found out how many journalists,
how many people who are writers,
how many people that are professionals,
how many people that work were on
adderall that I'm in.
I mean,
I live in an area where there's a lot of
people that have money and they work
real hard and because of the fact that
they need energy,
I know a shitload of people that are
taken adderall.
Yeah.
Folks that are in hollywood,
folks that are in finance,
all sorts of different.
Yeah,
I know quite a few also.
they,
it's everywhere,
man.
And it is such a,
you know,
the difference between methamphetamines
and amphetamines.
The difference between math and what
you're getting when you get adderall is
so god damn close.
So close.
But math,
it's crazy that you take that you're
fucking,
you're a meth head.
The only difference is how quick it hits
you.
It's literally the only difference.
And then the dosage that you get is
obviously regulated if you get adderall.
Right,
right.
I don't know.
I,
uh,
I'm not,
I'm not a pill guy.
I never have been.
What do you got here,
jamie?
We pull it up.
It says here about being on a treadmill.
Awesome.
I was on a treadmill for the first time
actually in quite a while and it was a
very steep angle and I was there for a
very long time.
He said they were surprised and they
said,
well,
you could stop now.
That's amazing.
I said,
I can go much longer than this if you
want me to hate trump.
I got to fucking right now,
buddy.
I got a challenge.
How about you joined the sober october
fitness challenge next year,
man,
hop on.
We'll put that strap on.
You will see what's up.
See what I'm saying?
Who's amazed?
A lot of mickey mantle gene.
Everything is over the top with trump.
Trump d dieted successfully before had
been more of a believer in diet because
I'm strong,
you know,
I've always been more of a believer in
diet cause I'm strong.
You know,
I hit the ball far.
I mean I'm strong physically.
He said,
that is so hilarious.
Will you imagined wrestling him how?
Wiki?
Westfield.
Just a bag of jello.
Just wrap up body and
it's all gushy.
The bones are barely held together by a
thread and I can.
What are you talking about?
Your ball far strung.
I mean when he said that he would beat
up joe barden.
That was my.
That was like a peak ludicrousness yeah.
Yeah.
Was like,
what you're going to beat up to joe
biden would go down fast and hard.
That's what he said.
Do it.
The fact that they're talking like that
again.
Absurd.
It's so fucking funny that bull and
biden has said the same thing.
Like he kick his ass.
He's a blake.
When did the truman and dewey trade
barbs like that?
Back in the day is.
What is he saying?
Nixon and kennedy.
I did make a mistake,
but they asked me what I like to debate
this gentleman.
I said,
no.
if we're in high school,
I've taken behind the gym and beat the
hell out of them mean well,
I don't believe that.
I think trump would kick his ass.
I really do.
Trump is meaner and I think biden would
make a mistake,
yet trump better be able to.
He would swing any would slip and he
would fall and he'd fuck is nea and
trump would kick him in the face like a
soccer ball.
He would get lucky,
he would walk away and biden would be
holding this teeth and blood coming out
of his mouth and he'd be like,
I told you in the best,
the best ever.
And he'd get away with it.
It gets away with a lot of things and
there'll be a lot of people want to kick
trump's ass and get back at them,
but it would never manifested,
so would never come to play.
Just like what's going on now.
It's like where people thought stormy
daniels going to take them down.
And then it turns out stormy daniels
beat some checkup on a porn set.
And,
and now she's after menotti also because
he,
uh,
apparently isn't giving her an
accounting of where all the money that
she raised a online was going to.
And he apparently filed.
She said he filed that lawsuit against
trump against her wishes.
She didn't want it done and now she,
she's not getting an accounting of the
money.
It's hilarious.
Defamation that she lost and now she has
to pay his legal,
his legal fees.
So this novel,
naughty guy's hilarious.
He wants to run for president.
Just another dummy in the mix.
Another dummy.
Listen to these.
He's another guy chain himself to a
building.
It's the same thing.
It's the same bull horn,
right?
He just wants attention.
I had actually talked to guys in
hollywood.
It works in hollywood.
He's like a high level guy.
He's got a respectable job and he's
like,
we need a guideline like that.
Have an audi guy on our side.
It doesn't talk any shit.
Why doesn't take any shit?
A guy who could call trump out on his
bullshit and I'm like,
what are you talking about man?
Like what are you talking about?
This guy,
this lawyer,
this guy's the guy you think you need
running the country.
Are you serious?
It's a disaster.
They wanted to believe that he was the
guy,
right?
It fit the narrative like,
yes,
we need a guy like that.
We need a good guy like trump.
You know keith olbermann is.
This is what all these people are a good
guy.
Who's gonna kill him.
You fat.
Fuck you fucking liar.
You pizza shit with trump.
Trump has nothing to lose is what it is.
Like trump could say anything and he
does because where they're going to do
well,
they're going to do.
He's one of the things about diet pills.
They're,
they're putting about amphetamines and
they were reading down in this article,
all of the side effects of the bonds of
grand juror,
elevated sense of your place in the
world.
Like all the is the president and on top
elevated sense of the president.
Wow.
That is great.
I'm the president of the world.
I think he thinks he is,
but he is.
He's.
He's fucking.
But it'd be visa president,
United States.
You're basically a pretty much president
of the world.
Yeah.
At least if there's a number one through
10,
your number one.
Yeah.
Alright.
Who's next?
Who's number two?
That is.
That's number two.
Is donald fucking trump all day.
One of my favorite hillary quilts is
really recently.
She was,
she said I would like to be president.
That's what she said.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I'd like to be president.
You should never be president then
because that's not what the job is.
That job's not some shit you put on your
resume.
Right?
Right.
To be president.
Like a cookie.
Yeah.
That's what it comes off as,
like to be the queen.
I was like that.
I would like,
if you kiss my ass,
I would suck my toes.
What would you would like it trump.
That's why trump comes off as like a,
just a bad stand up when he does those
rallies and everything.
Like you can tell when he's squinting at
the prompter.
And he was like,
we as americans must blah blah blah
blah.
And then you see his eyes open and he's
like,
so let me tell you if he's all prompter.
And that's when I go,
oh,
here it comes.
Here comes a winner.
And when he,
when he talks about ice and he's like
the men and women of ice,
just amazing people.
A job that none of us want to do.
We don't want to do.
And then he starts the crowd.
Work this guy over here,
look at him.
He didn't want to do it.
His wife knows what he's doing.
Crowd work like fuck.
It's the president.
It's so fucking bizarre.
Do you remember that one?
Ninety minute speech that he gave this
rambling nonsense that people go,
this is the day the presidency
unraveled.
It was two years ago.
That shit was forever ago.
And he's still unraveling.
It's,
it's,
uh,
he's not even unraveling.
It's just who he is.
Do we go back to the,
you know,
this guy as a whole and what we knew to
do because guaranteed in 2020,
that's going to be the pitch against
trump.
We need to return to some semblance of
society.
It's going to be a young democratic
socialist type character that says a lot
of things that the young people want to
hear.
And then it's like a completely anti
racist,
anti homophobic trans rights,
all that stuff.
That's what I think.
Someone who can hold it together and
someone doesn't have a good fucking box
above in the closet.
That's getting tougher and tougher to
find these days.
Man,
there is some shit just fucking
graveyards falling out of people's
closets.
It's people that want to be in power
that all have these fucking skeletons.
What's the weird things?
Is these people that want to be in
power?
Yeah,
I think it's hilarious.
Like you look at the.
I'm a politician like you just described
at a rally or a speech and behind them
is just,
it's so well choreographed,
like every nationality is represented
and you know,
you just see it looks like something out
of a fucking star trek episode that hats
from different lands and all kinds of
things and it's like that to me is just
as fake and and potentially offensive as
just the trump background.
White trash is like laura dern running
star trek or star wars.
Just what it's like bring it back.
Yes.
It's like,
oh,
okay.
I see what you're doing.
Now that laura dern is a bad actress.
She's a great actress.
But in that role and in this situation
and when she's like telling the pilot to
shut up and listen,
stop guys.
A fucking straight up killer is out
there flying as a pilot.
Piloting a spaceship,
getting down evil robots and want to
blow up the planet.
He's really going to be intimidated by
laura dern.
I remember when we first started running
this empathic,
shut the fuck up.
She's forced fed.
Just force fed.
Yeah.
These,
these really obvious.
There's this theatrical plays at
diversity and inclusiveness,
aggressiveness and you could tell that
they,
like they've pushed every,
there's no authenticity to their,
their message.
They have to push every correct button
and say all the right notes and make all
the right sounds.
It's.
Yeah.
It's like this thing,
they're,
they're complying.
It's a compliance thing as much as it is
an expression of who they are as
individuals and have to be compliant
with this new,
this new way.
People are thinking and behaving but,
but it's so ham handed,
like,
like it's really over the top.
It's obvious.
It's like a guy named wiener pulling his
dick out.
It's not too obvious.
It's too clunky,
too.
Right on the head.
You know what I heard that some of the
movies that are coming out,
um,
I think they're doing a girl version of
bad boys.
Oh,
which is like,
why the fuck they doing ghostbusters,
like ghost busters,
which was such a success.
Uh,
and then I saw this.
Isn't my logo kicked off a twitter?
Yeah.
Yeah,
like goofing on.
Uh,
what's her name there?
I'm leslie.
Leslie jones.
Yeah.
So I,
I read this the other day,
uh,
there's a broadway show of king kong is
now a broadway musical and they have
this amazing kind of marionette gorilla
on the stage giant fucking thing.
And the girl that plays a,
an darrow,
uh,
and,
and now a new girl has been cast.
She's black now.
I'm like this,
the whole gist
of king kong is the fact that it's a
white broad,
like the whole island is full of black
chicks.
Whoa.
This,
this marionette king kong picks her up.
What's up with his face?
I don't know.
They had to make them,
you know,
almost uh,
the characters look in the lion king
musical.
Something weird.
Yeah.
So is that,
that's all I'm marrying it yet.
It's like a fucking,
it's on cables and,
and shit and just people working it.
And how strange it.
If you,
if there's a video clip of it and you
see it kind of move,
it's a.
It is strange.
We got to see a video,
but like I said,
the whole fucking thing is based on.
It's the white chick.
Yeah,
like,
like it,
it's part of the story.
I can understand.
You can cast a black actress and a white
actress as part as that,
but when it's so integral to the story
that this fucking got.
Yeah,
that's sick.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
It looks pretty fucking bad ass.
But where's this for?
What's this guy get out of their buddy?
Wow.
This is amazing.
Yeah.
Isn't that second a fucking a broadway
stage?
They got all this that's going on.
It really is.
That really is amazing.
They got the teeth lit up and
everything.
Yeah.
The lighting is pretty important and
pretty
bad ass.
So this was the old one.
The old one used to be a blonde chick.
Yeah.
No,
not anymore in our hands.
We're going to get a black trans man.
I mean,
the whole gimmick is that kang has been
on this island with black chicks and he
sees her and just loses his fucking
mind.
Yeah.
I have a whole bit of bike hurt it the
other night.
It's the fucking brilliant.
It's so goddamn funny.
But it is true.
It's like that movie is like the most
racist movie of all time.
All right.
So when,
when the remake came out,
I think it was Peter Jackson remake came
out,
um,
patrice went off on it and did a whole
thing about what the movie represents
and what the chicken and the gorilla
represents an hour and it was fucking
brilliant.
Only as patrice could have done it.
Uh,
and he,
you know,
he nailed it.
Do you know the movie frozen?
The little kids moving.
I never saw it.
Girl who
can fucking turning things into ice.
There's a disney version of live does
diversion that they've decided to do.
And in the live disney version there,
the girl is now played by a black girl,
but it's,
it's a blonde girl who lives in like
Norway.
It doesn't make sense.
They've decided to have her be played by
a black girl and people went crazy.
They send all these emails in like,
this is outrageous,
like what are you do?
And it's like,
yeah,
but I feel like these companies,
they,
it's,
there's too many people involved.
Right.
It's not like compound media.
It's just the anthony kumi and making
decisions.
Right.
With something like disney,
you have this board and you probably in
California,
you have to have a certain amount of
women on the board.
Right?
Imagine what that must be like.
You have to have equal
representation of everyone.
Everyone's super concerned about
diversity,
like at a fundraising pitch to show.
And when they walked in there,
the first question they said he pitched
the show.
They go,
okay,
where's the diversity?
Where's the diversity?
Like he was pitching a sitcom.
It's like,
I'm just pitching you something funny.
A pitch.
You a funny program.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
We need a,
we need an asian man,
black woman.
We needed this and that.
And again,
like we were talking about it,
it's so obvious that it becomes
distracting.
Like I don't want.
I don't want to have to watch something
that,
that diversity is just forced in there.
Right,
because you,
you notice it and now you're distracted
and you can't really enjoy the things
like that king kong thing,
like how do you,
how do they do the part where the,
the,
the natives on skull island,
a kong is just like ah,
get outta here,
but this one is like,
oh,
this,
there has to be something different and
it's definitely the hair color and skin
guy.
It's just what it was.
It's regardless of how horrible it is
or,
or whatever past.
That's just the way it is.
Roll up.
Right and move on.
I.
Yeah.
Time has passed you by old man.
Old white dude.
Yeah.
Oh,
old white dude doesn't like when a black
woman gets her role for all black women,
all white women.
There are so many instances where that's
fine and no one would notice and
whatever.
I don't even,
I don't have a problem with hamilton or
whatever.
They want to cast founding fathers as
black and hispanic dudes whatevs go at
it.
But like when it's an integral part of
the story,
it's most of the stories.
It's most of the reason why loses his
mind.
He falls in love with the white chick a
whole time.
He's.
He's on camera in the movie.
They're losing his mind because of the
white chick that,
yeah,
just don't make a movie then just don't,
don't make the movie or don't make the
play the.
I didn't get to make the playbook.
We're going to have a black woman of
color.
I'm going to have a young woman of
That's my favorite criticisms is how
dare to white people have this
discussion without a person of color.
Well,
that's true.
Yeah.
We'll probably catch shit for this,
but it's from who?
From who?
That can go fuck themselves.
Who would you propose this idea?
The idea that.
Wait,
hold on.
Anthony.
Before we go any further,
let's bring it a person of color.
Yeah.
A person of color.
How should we.
We are.
We were too privileged people.
We shouldn't be discussing.
That is true.
But you can't even communicate about
something.
No,
no you can't.
And all we hear about is how we need an
open and honest discussion about race.
And then the second year try to half
one,
shut up.
Don't talk about.
Here's one that everybody keeps
ignoring.
You want to know what's racist?
Harvard tries really hard to keep asian
people out.
Yeah.
Make you get way more difficult because
asian people are far better at school
than white people.
Just the way it is.
And they have to balance it.
It would be full of asians if everybody
was,
uh,
got accepted for qualifications,
that would be asian,
harvard.
But it is amazing.
The people that are rallying against
racial discrimination don't look at that
because that is absolute racial
discrimination.
But on the other end of the spectrum,
right,
right.
You're taking these people that are,
they are a minority.
There are a small percentage of the
population and they vastly outperform
most other groups.
Yeah.
And because of that,
harvard has made it more difficult for
them to get in.
And now there's a giant class action
lawsuit against one of the most liberal
and progressive institutes of higher
learning ever racist.
They're fucking undeniably racist is
racist.
Yeah.
It's the superior people.
It's absolutely based on nothing but
someone's race,
ethnic background and uh,
they're,
they're doing it.
Yeah.
They're doing it for now,
for now.
But you don't hear about this from the
social justice warriors and now no race
baiters they want to go on about white
privilege and yeah,
it,
it really is.
Look,
I,
I just like bringing shit up that I
notice and if I notice that they're
squeezing diversity into something that
doesn't need it,
I,
I think it looks like I said distracting
and it's out of place.
And then other things,
like the other day I noticed,
uh,
and,
and you probably shouldn't even say it,
that the,
a mars probe that just landed on mars
and they showed the control room at jet
propulsion laboratories and they're all
applauding.
Could possibly be the least diverse room
I've ever seen in my life.
A bunch of white nerds.
That's all it was.
There were a couple of like a big women,
like,
like a kind of,
you know,
lesbians,
a couple of them in there.
But for the most part,
it was every nerdy guy grown up and
landing a fucking spec,
a billion miles away on fucking mars.
It's insane because when it push comes
to shove,
you need the people that can get the job
done and if it's that room of people,
it's that room of people.
You can't artificially diversify
something just for the optic and get the
job done.
They had.
Everyone in that room had a reason to be
there and I assume it's based on
qualifications,
but if you notice that or mention it,
I'm sure I'll be called a fucking racist
for that.
Yeah,
for sure.
Don't ever notice things you can't
switch.
The rule is don't notice.
Trends.
Don't notice things.
I feel like that's going away though.
You really do.
I just,
I don't see it lasting.
I feel like it's a,
a bright wave of nonsense that's hitting
us and it's going to balance back out
and rational thinking is,
can you.
Here's the thing,
this is one of the things that drives me
crazy.
It's like,
you know,
address your white privilege.
Recognize your white privilege.
No.
You know why
I'm not racist?
Okay,
so if I'm not racist,
you should be concentrating on racism.
He shouldn't be concentrating on people
who don't experience racism because
there fortunately white,
because I didn't do anything,
didn't do anything just by being,
but what they're doing is they're
putting you in a position where you're
always guilty and once they put you in
that box,
they always can shut you up because
there the logic is not very good.
So the discourse is not.
It's not well thought out.
It's not really nuanced.
So because of that,
they want to be able to just push a
button and shut you off.
That button is the white privilege
button.
But that's.
You're looking at.
You're looking at a reality.
Yeah.
Do white people have it easier than
people who get racially discriminated
against?
Yes,
but the problem is not the white people
that have it easy.
The problem is the people that racially
discriminate.
Yeah.
So you're looking at the wrong thing.
So you're finding somebody you want to
make them a bad person just by being
the.
The,
the thing that you've decided is the
oppressor.
Yeah.
It's a racist thing.
Everything is the same level,
whether you have an opinion about
something,
just voicing an opinion about something
that involves race or sexuality or
whatever it is,
and literally calling for violence
against people of.
It's all in the same category when it's
ridiculous.
You could have your,
your personal opinion on anything that
is sensitive these days,
like I said,
race or sexuality or what have you.
It doesn't mean anything unless you use
some kind of negativity or oppression or
something against,
uh,
the person because of your opinion.
Uh,
until you do that,
you just have a fucking opinion and it's
not all that dangerous.
Uh,
patrice used to say that too.
He goes,
I never met a racist in my life because
I never met one,
never sat down and had someone calling
the n word or anything like that.
He goes to never met one.
He's been in the wrong places.
Maybe take them to some places,
but,
but it's like,
let's say you have somebody that has a
low opinion of,
of black people and,
and just go into a bar.
You sit down and there's a black dude
sitting there and watching the yankee
game or something and go,
uh,
he goes,
hey,
look at that.
The yankees are winning.
D is the guy gotta to turn around and
go,
fuck you dropping bombs or is it going
to go?
Yeah,
I guess so.
Like,
like there's,
there's levels of,
of that.
He might have an idea about it,
but until you start exercising that I
don't honestly don't see a problem with
it.
This piece of discrimination eight,
and they have discrim discriminatory
ideas about all sorts of things.
It's just when you allow some but don't
allow others when you allow
discrimination against white people,
but you don't allow it against black.
Create resentment when you allow
discrimination against men,
but don't allow it against women because
you feel like women have been
victimized.
So it's our time.
It's our turn will know it doesn't work
that way.
It doesn't work that way.
Especially when you're talking to people
that aren't rapists.
Call everybody a rapist and the people
who aren't rapists,
you go,
oh,
okay.
So you think everybody's a rapist will
you?
Will you are fucking crazy.
And then they start changing what?
Rape,
right?
Yeah.
Well that's what the,
that's kind of what they've done.
I mean obviously the uh,
like the louis ck situation,
I know that is so people are so divided
on that one and my opinion is if,
if he didn't do anything or make anyone
do anything against their will,
he's just a guy that has a strange
proclivity,
you know,
he likes jerking off in front of people.
Apparently the cat's out of the bag
there,
but like where those girls that upset 20
years ago with a that upset 20 years ago
that,
that now it's an issue or with a giggle
where they let,
like I need to know how they were then
because I don't give a fuck what you
think now.
Like at the time,
what was it?
Okay.
Was it cool with you?
Oh,
did you sit there and fucking rib the
elbow to the ribs with you girlfriend?
I go look at this guy jerking off in
front of us.
Uh,
to me,
I don't care what,
what time is done because it,
the,
the way something looks,
the morality or ethics or respect that
is expected in 2018 ain't what it was 20
years ago.
So you can't be held liable for
something you did 20 years ago when it
was normal or a little strange or
whatever the fuck it was.
Well,
I think it's always been weird to beat
off in front of people.
That's an odd thing to do.
I think about it as though he asked if
he could write,
and this is something that I've brought
up to people go,
you know,
when people say,
oh,
you know,
he would lock these women in the room
and beat off to stop the.
If you're to,
if you get like,
push this,
you're saying that because that fits
your narrative.
He's this abusive person who's abusing
his power.
Now here's another problem with that.
When this was all going down,
he wasn't very famous.
No,
that's just a tosa.
What power was he abusing it?
He,
he was a successful comedian.
He was admired by his peers because he
was really funny.
He wasn't louis c,
k like the superstar filling out madison
square garden,
louis ck.
It wasn't the same guy,
you know,
he,
he didn't even have all the hbo specials
and all the netflix specials was the
same guy.
So he was just another comic that like
to beat off in front of people and he
would ask first.
So when you say that he,
you know,
forced these women and wouldn't let them
leave,
none of them say that.
In fact he asked and when they said no,
he didn't do it,
he didn't say,
oh,
well good.
You don't want me to beat off that.
Make it feel even better when I beat off
in front of you.
Shut the fuck up and sit down.
You know,
he doesn't do anything.
No.
He was asking which is,
which is so strange but weird thing.
It's not.
It's not in the same realm as,
as harvey weinstein's.
It's not
even fucking know.
It's not even close.
It's not even close,
but people don't want you to
rationalize.
Don't want you to grade things.
They just want to talk about abuse.
All abuse gets shoveled into this one
little pie chart area like this is male
abusers,
and then they'll put matt lauer right
next to bill cosby,
right next to louis ck.
Like,
well,
this seems kind of crazy.
And then when you say it's crazy,
like matt damon said,
let's,
I think we should make a distinction.
Oh yeah,
you can't be,
you become a rape apologist and say
things like that.
And uh,
it's weird because it's odd because even
saying the word rape these days,
like a little red flag goes off in your
head.
Like,
how did I say that?
Did I say,
did I say it evil?
And it was a sound.
Evil are salivating,
right?
Don't be salivating,
don't smile when you say it's very
somber.
It,
it is strange.
It's this,
uh,
I use the term all the time because it's
the only one that really fits orwellian.
Everything is so strange now it,
if you read 1984 years ago,
you couldn't fathom things getting like
that.
But man,
in some cases it's even worse than,
than expected.
You think there aren't an unperson you
don't think there's an unpaid Alex Jones
unperson wipe them clean from the
[inaudible] that's it.
Uh,
the,
this,
uh,
new speak words are twisted,
like it means the opposite of what it
was supposed to me.
And,
and uh,
it,
it's something that you never thought
would happen to.
I always thought like,
we read a book like that or some other
kind of this dystopian story.
You get like a,
a,
like an orb is supposed to be some kind
of orb with the government looking at
you and don't do that,
sir.
Twenty six,
53.
Oh,
to sit down and then it's like,
oh fuck.
It was us.
Oh,
where the rats,
we,
we pick up our phone and we rat each
other out and we're big brother.
Like we turned out to be the bad guy.
The collective this not the government.
They like,
like,
oh boy,
you're going to.
The government's got to put a tracking
device on you.
Fuck that.
He comes to my house and wants to put
out.
I'll shoot them.
I don't care.
Oh,
you forgot your phone.
Don't,
don't leave your house without your
fucking tracking device,
like it's the same thing and they do use
those and chronic case,
everything is presented as a
convenience.
When I first got easy pass,
it was like,
this is awesome.
I don't have to wait on a line at a toll
booth and throw change in or something.
I'm whizzing right through and then I
see a story.
It's like,
oh,
easy pass use in a divorce case to see
what the husband was going here or
there.
And it's like,
oh,
that's handy.
That's handy.
And then you see on the insurance
commercials,
it's like,
use the safe driver thing.
It goes in your car and it acts like a,
a plain black box.
And,
and it shows how safety driving they'll
reduce your rates.
It's like,
really?
it's not going to be used if I'm
speeding again into accident for them to
go,
yeah,
we're not paying your fucking thing
because obviously we'd read that you
were speeding and,
uh,
and,
and didn't stop or like it's all
presented as a convenience.
Alexa,
you literally your tvs,
they all wrap you out.
It's alexa isn't this magic thing that
everything happens internally.
That shit sends everything you say out
records it somewhere and then sends
whatever answer it's supposed to give
back back to it and that's what it is.
But everything is saved and do you
really know when it's listening and when
your toe you say certain things.
I had alexa for a little while.
I don't know why all I ever did was like
alexa,
whether that will tell me the weather I
could have checked on my phone and then
it started doing things like I just be
watching tv and it wouldn't be like I
don't have an answer for that.
Like,
yeah,
I don't need that shit.
I don't know what it's doing.
I don't know what it listening in
dialogue from the television from maybe
the tv.
Maybe it's just listening to every
fucking thing I say and sending a
transcript somewhere because then you
could go to the app on your phone and
every question you ever asked it is
listed there in text.
Fucking form.
Swear to you.
Every conversation you have with that
goddamn thing is somewhere.
Well,
hey dad,
what are you worried about?
There you go.
Well,
hey,
hey.
Hey.
as long as it keeps us safe.
Right?
Right.
Can you say about how about yeah,
if you're not doing anything bad,
well in 10 years,
will this be bad?
In five years,
just like shit that 20 years ago it
wasn't bad.
Now it's a fucking crime.
You'll be exIled from society.
I don't know if what I'm saying now can
be brought up in 10 years and you know,
when I play video games I say some
pretty nasty shit,
but uh,
yeah,
I don't want to alexa or,
or my smart tv,
listen to every fucking thing I say and
record transcripts of what I'm talking
about and we bring it in our house.
No one's forcing you to put this fucking
rad.
Now's you.
You paid for it,
you spend money and you put it there and
plugged it in yourself.
It's amazing how we went from not
trusting anything.
I remember when online shopping for a
started and you're like,
I'm not putting my credit card in there
now you're laughing.
What are you kidding?
You just drove through twin 20 face
scanners,
license plate scanners to get here.
Your,
your card is being picked up by a sensor
so they can target,
advertise you in the mall,
so there's no privacy anymore and we
love it.
We love that.
There's no privacy.
I don't want to go to the mall for
christmas.
I go to amazon and now there's a lIst of
every fucking thing I buy at amazon
that's being sent to everyone all over
the place.
You think you've got privacy.
Fuck you.
You can't even move to a Montana anymore
in a cabin and be off the grid,
which just doesn't happen.
So I love jesse.
Jesse,
jesse.
When it does,
I'm off the grid.
I,
I'm going to Mexico and I'm off the grid
and it's like he's got a show called off
the grid.
It's like,
well,
Yeah,
you're on the grid guy mma,
a fighter governor.
He's a.
Yeah,
he's off The grid,
but he's constantly on the grid.
There's no off the grid anymore.
There's no awkward.
The whole world's going to be on the
grid.
Yeah,
the whole world.
That's what they're targeting.
Expand these satellite imagery things
for uh,
for um,
the internet doing that as well.
Where are going To have satellite
internet available everywhere all over
the world,
all over the world.
And everybody up to speed.
And I was talking about this with
somebody else.
Isn't it amazing that gps has worked for
as long as it has?
Yeah,
flawlessly.
It's amazing how good it was.
Never a problem inch by inch like
literally tells you turn right.
And you're right there.
And I think we have the dumbed down
version,
like the military has that,
the premium version like sure.
But yeah,
by the,
by the inch and we have,
you know,
buy a couple of feet.
But it's to me it's amazing that like
it's worked this long.
It never goes out.
like oh,
it's really had it on cd rom and my car
in 1998 styling.
Yeah.
I had the early version of of that and
it was a big stupid thing that had to
sit on top of the roof of my car to
catch up to catch the satellite,
like a disc or like some,
some weird antenna that had to go up
there.
They used to have to have to pick up
the,
uh,
the gps and the satellites aren't any
different,
but the receivers are like,
can be a lot smaller and fucking phones
in your fucking things up while it's in
your pocket.
They're tracking you while it's in your
pocket,
in your car,
as you're driving course,
when it's off,
when it's,
I don't trust any of these electronics.
I use them.
I'm not going to throw my fucking phone
away and,
and if I do forget it,
there's no board horrifying feeLing than
driving away from your house and go,
oh fuck,
I don't have my tracking device.
And you will turn around and get it
because you can't function without it.
It's everything to people.
Again,
if,
if there was that emp or whatever the
fuck it is,
that just zaps the grid,
you would say pandemonium in no time.
Well,
you would see pandemonium.
It was just the power grid went down for
any reason.
If someone like a terrorist attack took
out the power grid,
we need power way more than we think we
do.
Oh,
absolutely.
You think nothing of.
We in New York,
we had a hurricane a few years ago,
like five or six years ago,
I guess it was,
and I'm the one that took out jersey and
long island and stuff.
And uh,
we went nine days without power in the
house on long island.
And you could see it fraying around the
edges,
man.
Society,
just the first couple of days you'd be
on online at the gas station of philip
jerry cans to take back to your
generators at the house.
And it's like,
oh,
okay.
Excuse me.
Oh no.
Oh,
you were first guy had got hit by that
seventh,
eighth day.
It got,
fuck.
You know,
I was standing here.
Go fuck yourself.
Get to the back of the line now.
Could you imagine if that was you trying
to get your kids medication or something
or food like it just goes a little
longer and now foods getting a little
scarce,
you are going to have a problem and I am
stunned.
It hasn't happened to any extent.
Really.
We saw,
we saw close with katrina,
I think,
uh,
and violence started.
That was,
that was a little out of hand,
but use app that grid give people,
they have nothing.
I wound up getting a giant fucking,
like a cummings generator.
This thing like is for backup power at
hospitals.
So when the power goes out in my
neighborhood,
literally my pool is running flood
lights in the backyard.
Every tv's on it comes on automatically.
It just sit there as if fuel with,
eh,
it's a liquid propane,
but I have to 1000 gallon tanks buried
in my front yard.
What?
So it would,
it would,
it would last for a long fucking time.
Lungs in time.
Uh,
uh,
depending on how much you use because,
the more,
uh,
the more draw on it,
the heart of the engine's got to work.
So it depends if I'm running my whole
house,
I don't know,
it would last a few weeks and it's safe
to that propane to be in those cans on
underground?
No,
they're a giant tax.
They're running natural gas into my
neighborhood so I might have a converted
over to natural gas.
But I like the fact that if the gas
breaks too,
I can still at least jacka an lp truck
somewhere and fill up my own tank.
You know,
crazy push came to shove,
but it is just every light in the house
can be on my neighborhood's dark.
I'm just looking at it like an half
fuckers that happened.
A.
Yeah.
A few times.
I'm waiting for a big one though.
Like I really want to be bad blackout
just so I can dig it and know that
you're the guy with the power that say
the guy with refrigerants where the guns
come in.
like it really is it.
There is something a little creepy about
the pRospect that we are really
delicately balanced as a society.
It could really fly apart.
We truSt too much that the power is just
going beyond thAt the water's gonna run
that the food's going to be at the
supermarket or whatever the fuck it is.
like you got a great advantage being
able to hunt.
They get how many people don't know.
Do you know what american refugees would
look like?
The fat fucking mess.
Crossing some border to Canada to be
saved from some cataclysm that happened
down here.
What?
A bunch of fucking.
Just weak soft.
No nothing.
Every convenience they've used for
years.
Just not trained in the feeding yourself
outside in the wild.
They have no idea.
You ever skin an animal?
You ever kill something to eat a do?
Do you know how to get water from just
the humidity in the air or there are
things that we just don't know because
we depend on technology and we trust
that it's always going to be there
because it has been.
I mean,
you know,
we get very complacent,
but that's why if it ever failed,
whoa,
fuck you better hunker down somewhere.
It's crazy.
Indeed.
And on that note,
do we just did like four hours on it
seems like it flew right by.
Did floor.
That is nuts,
joe.
I gotta.
Thank you man.
Thank you.
I love being on your show for real.
You're the reason why this all happened.
It's crazy now.
People know it's fucking nuts.
I,
I love it.
I love always good seeing my friend very
much.
Cool.
Oh,
the gentleman.
Yeah.
He's got a book out permanently
suspended.
Available,
uh,
anywhere.
Go to compound media.com
for all the details.
All right.
Oh yeah.
Awesome.